I'm undefeated. I knew for a fact. I was like, "Dude, it's There
it is. There it is." Yes. This judge doesn't even believe in
consent videos. Hey. Hey, kid. Do you take the last cookie? No.
No. He's got chocolate like literally in his eyebrows. The judge
literally doesn't believe you in this specific instance because
you're a lying.
Let's get into the the free Jack D stuff cuz I think basically
from this video he's got a website with transcripts and we could
try to see like exactly what the evidence was and everything.
My name's Jack. I'm a content creator or I used to be until I
had my life torn apart by a false accusation. Since this situation
went public, I've received death threats. I've been banned from
establishments. All of my YouTube channels have been taken down.
I've lost friends. I've lost work opportunities. Pretty much
everything. I'm innocent. That's all I got to say really. Everybody
knows I'm innocent. I did not want to have to make this video,
but I've been silent on this issue for as long as possible and
enough is enough. My appeal was this month and I'm waiting on
the decision. So, I still have to be extremely careful about
what I say. My goal with this video is to share what happened
in a nonbiased a way as I possibly can. I'm
>> You can't You literally are incapable.
>> You're You're the accused.
You cannot present this in a non-biased way.
try my best not to be emotional and just be completely neutral
here and share objective facts. >> Who is this guy? This
is a Canadian pickup artist who has basically been convicted
of assault. He
he was sentenced to 3 years in prison and he says he's innocent.
The whole thing was make made up. Okay, that's what it is. >> Facts
and evidence to show my innocence. the timelines of the encounter,
inconsistencies in the evidence and testimony, and that there
are enough inconsistencies to make you go read the full testimony
yourself. Legally, I'm not allowed to say as much as I would
like to, but I'm going to do my best to share what I can. Before
anything else, I do want to say this. I believe survivors of
assault and false accusations of assault deserve to be taken
seriously and treated with compassion. I've been through both.
Nothing I'm about to say is meant to
>> Okay, don't do
don't do a This is better than Teone, but don't be don't be techone.
I've been both >> minimize real harm. >> That being
said, let's get into it. In February 2021, I was falsely accused
and charged with assault from a consensual encounter between
myself and a woman in August 2020. I'll refer to her as the accuser.
My legal team and I spent several years going back and forth
to get records and evidence to help my case and we finally went
to trial in 2024 and the judge wrongfully convicted me. I say
wrongfully as I have always maintained my innocence and I will
explain why in a bit. Based on how things go with my appeal,
there are two options. Either the appellent court will order
me a new trial or I'll have to spend 3 years in jail for something
I didn't do and my life is essentially over. And in the meantime,
there's been newspaper articles, there's been documentaries and
all kinds of misinformation put out. So now I'm going to go over
some information to help you get a better grip of what actually
happened at the time of the incident. >> Okay. I mean,
he's not attacking the other person. As long as he like holds
himself back from attacking the other person, I'm I'm willing
to take a look. I'm willing to be unbiased. Actually >> I
was a YouTuber, actor, filmmaker, and primarily known for pranks.
I've been working full time. >> Jack Denmo. Okay. >> And
earning a living as a content creator since approximately 2016.
I met the accuser after matching with her on Tinder. On that
day, this person managed to find me and my camera crew in a crowd
of 10,000 people in order to be interviewed. After matching on
Tinder, we messaged on Instagram, texting and flirting. I recognized
her from one of my party videos, McMaster Hokco 2019. On that
day, this person >> So, the person from Tinder was was
basically doing an interview or something. She's not featured
in any of the footage I'm showing. Okay. So, this girl was in
a video he did and she matched with him on Tinder. managed to
find me and my camera crew in a crowd of 10,000 people in order
to be interviewed. After matching on Tinder, we messaged on Instagram,
texting and flirting before agreeing to meet up. The accuser
drove approximately 30 minutes from Oakville to my house in Hamilton,
Ontario. I invited her in. I showed her around and then she asked
for a tour of my YouTube studio. I suggested we should go for
a hike. We then left my house and drove to a hiking trail. But
upon arriving, it was getting dark, so we agreed to return to
my house and watch Netflix and chill. Upon returning to my >> it
sounded like she was down at Netflix to chill before that. Why
the did you go for a drive, dude? Weird weird fumble.
Why don't you show me your YouTube studio? He's like, let's go
for a hike. She didn't wear hiking shoes. The are you talking
about? >> We did just that. We watched Netflix and we had
a consensual encounter. I'm not proud to admit this, but at the
time I was sleeping around with a bunch of different women. The
accuser also had multiple different partners. recently before
me as per DNA evidence, as well as confirming sleeping with an
alleged boyfriend just a few days prior to meeting me. Now, to
clarify, this is not a judgment on her character, right? >> Alleged
boyfriend.
Okay. It's not a judgment on her character. I
Oh, he's going to have to say, well, it affects the evidence
of the trial, but it's not a judgment on her character. Otherwise,
it feels like an extraneous detail. But if he if he explains
how it's maybe just like because of evidence in the trial and
how it was presented in terms of he mentioned DNA evidence, it's
like, okay, I could see maybe there's like some reason to mention
>> rather it's to provide context on our generation's modern
culture of frequent hookups. In retrospect, I definitely should
not have been sleeping with these women, but I was a young >> Oh,
this is stupid. Oh, no. >> And I was famous on the internet.
I would often film a quick consent video when having encounters
with strangers that knew I had a large following as a proactive
way to ensure I had clear consent from whoever I was hooking
up with, especially women who have been featured in I don't nobody
doubts. Okay, this guy I hope he understands that I'm not going
to doubt that this woman wanted to you when she went to your
house. Nobody here is going to doubt that when you started having
she wanted to you
right. That's That isn't I don't even
We'll have to see. Maybe Maybe her testimony will be like, "Oh,
well, I do I wanted to do nothing with this guy." Maybe, right?
Maybe he did did the Chappelle meme, the the contract. I don't
mind if people do this like if they're famous and they're like
literally they they are meeting somebody who knows they have
clout and wants to them because of clout. I don't care if people
do this. It's fine. >> A previous video of mine. This is
not a normal way to live, but it is common in society and especially
amongst athletes, celebrities, and public figures. So, during
our encounter, I attempted to film a consent video, and she informed
me that she didn't want to be recorded. So, I stopped the recording
and deleted whatever was briefly recorded right in front of her.
We then continued what we were doing, having a consensual encounter.
I want to be very clear here. The encounter was enthusiastic,
ongoing. There was no confusion about it. She was consenting,
as was I. She communicated consent in many different ways, particularly
verbally, asking me to spend her and telling me drinks. [__]
daddy, amongst other things. >> Yeah, I don't like I don't
like this. I'm already Okay.
When you when you do these details like ahead of time, you're
preloading all of the context in, right? You're pre-loading like
a bunch of stuff in people's brains to try to get them on your
side. And I'm see it's red flag. Okay, red flag. We should be
we should be cognizant every time we see a red flag come up.
It's a it's we have to point it out. Okay. He's already said
he started filming without consent. Well, he said he was filming
a consent video before they hooked up. That's a little different,
right? It's not a It's not a video. He's saying he's saying he
started recording cuz he was like, "Hey, could we record this
video?" And then she said, "No." And he went, "Okay." And paused
and deleted. I'm guessing there was like an actual argument there
and he is just moving past it. Yes. Yes. It's a consent video
that they were going to like as in a we're going to hook up.
Are you cool with us hooking up? The moment she said no consent
video, he should have kicked her out. Uh, I don't think that's
true. I I feel like personally I wouldn't be shocked if a woman
was weirded out by the concept of a consent video because you're
literally saying you're you're Yeah, you're literally
make sure there's a record that nothing happened here was bad.
And it's like, well, I don't know what's going to happen here.
Why? Why are you getting me to what? What?
Right. I It does seem a little odd to ask for a consent video.
I I wouldn't be shocked if a woman was like, "Well, what do you
want to do that you think [snorts] think this is weird?"
It was
I He didn't present it that way, right? We'll see. We'll see
what he >> Text on our generation's modern culture of frequent
hookups. In retrospect, I definitely should not have been sleeping
with these women, but I was a young guy and I was famous on the
internet. I would often film a quick consent video when having
encounters with strangers that knew I had a large following as
a proactive way to ensure I had clear consent from whoever I
was hooking up with, especially women who have been featured
in a previous video of mine.
Okay, so this is going to make a huge difference is when did
he start recording this video? Because did he pull out his phone
and say, "I want a consent video." in the middle of, but he actually
pulled out his phone to record and then when when she saw the
camera, she freaked out and he went, "Well, no, I just want to
make sure that there's proof that you consented."
That would be interesting. I wonder how that gets laid out in
the transcripts. >> this is not a normal way to live, but
it is common in society and especially amongst athletes, celebrities,
and public figures. So during our encounter, I attempted to film
a consent video and she informed me that she didn't want to be
recorded. So I stopped the recording and deleted whatever was
briefly record >> Oh, that does seem that does seem possibly
slimy, right, during our encounter. And then
and then she asked me and then I had to delete it in front of
her.
I do think there's like if you were doing this with your clothes
on, I'm not sure she'd be like, "Delete it in front of me right
now." You know what I you know what I mean? That sounds a little
bit like uh delete it in front of me right now. That sounds like
he pulled his phone out and started recording
and then she said, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Off >> recorded
right in front of her." We then continued what we were doing,
having a consensual encounter. I wanted
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mis I misread this when I first heard
it. Thank you for pointing this out, guys. Definitely. Bro, we
continued having a consensual encounter. That sounds like you
pulled your phone out to start recording her without her consent
and then she freaked out and then you continued somehow.
Which by the way, as soon as that happens, one, the woman should
be getting the [__] out of there. But two,
like
now I'm dubious about what happens after that.
There's like a negative piece that happened. Okay, >> let
me be very clear here. The encounter was enthusiastic, ongoing.
There was no confusion about it. She was consenting as was I.
She communicated consent in many different ways, particularly
verbally, asking me to spend her and telling me dur
amongst other things. I don't want to repeat them, but you can
go and read the things that she said to me.
I don't want to repeat them. Well, you've just repeated them
>> in the transcripts. After finishing our encounter, we
chatted briefly before I politely told her I had to be up early
in the morning and I asked her to leave. That was the conclusion
of the date. Quoting from the court transcript, although the
accuser originally told police that she was obviously fine with
being asked to leave, her testimony at trial revealed otherwise.
She admitted that the dismissal did not feel good and she agreed
with trial counsel that she felt worthless because she was treated
as a conquest or notch on Mr. Densor's bed post. So, in hindsight,
I can absolutely see why this would make her feel bad. She had
traveled to see me. She was texting her friends and family about
me and our date ahead of time. in particular, some high expectations
for me. Kicking her out was rude and dismissive. I didn't think
that way at the time, but
I regret how I handled that. And if I could go back, I would
do things differently. With that being said, all of the activity
that we did was consensual. And when I say >> and then
you go into things, the things that you could have done differently,
right? But then again, you confirm that twice now. So, I don't
want to press charges or anything because part of me feels like
there are no boundaries to do that. Do you see that there? Yes.
Have I read that correctly?
Just me in my head being dramatic, right? Yes. Because you knew
even at the time that there are no boundaries. There's no way
you could do something like that in terms of pressing charges
because you're blowing it out of proportion and that you're being
dramatic, right? I'm not sure what I what I meant by no boundaries.
Boundaries means borders, right? I don't mean ambiguous or neutral.
I mean it was enthusiastic, encouraging, and ongoing. To put
it simply, the whole thing was a typical one night stand. Just
to be clear, my charge had nothing to do with filming a consent
video. It was entirely based on an allegation that I non-consensually
assaulted this person. This was shocking to me. It absolutely
destroyed my mental health. And for months, I was so confused.
What the [__] am I being charged with? We do know
what the reasons were now, and we'll get into those later, but
I was char What the am I being charged with? We do know.
>> I mean, you there's no way you went months without knowing
what you're being charged for. I believe that is like a requirement
when you're arrested or when you're booked in any case, right?
Hey, this is what you get to hear your
Although the factual conclusion was not mandatory given the evidence,
reaching it meant that when SM left Mr. Densore's home, she believed
he possessed a compromising video of her on his phone, which
increased the probitative value of evidence supporting a potential
motive to fabricate.
Uh, [laughter]
yeah. Okay.
I mean, that's clearly a scummy move to say. Oh, it's just a
consent video, guys. Just a consent video. Oh my god,
Potential motive to fabricate. As Justice
proved value of evidence supporting a potential motive to fabricate.
As Justice Crochenko concluded, SM's most significant concern
was that Mr. Densore had images or videos of her on his phone.
Considering that Mr. Denor had already shown a propensity to
disrespect her. It was essential to consider whether SM made
this assault allegation partly or fully to prompt police to access
his device, especially since the police apparently would not
take action unless she made a formal complaint. In R versus
WDM, is
this is a different Canadian case. It looks like uh the Saskatchewan
Court of Appeals stated that where credibility is a central issue
and there is evidence suggesting a complaint may have been motivated
to fabricate an allegation against the accuser, the tri of fact
is required to consider this information. So,
okay, they're looking at this and saying, well, it's possible,
they think it's possible that she fabricated this so that she
could get access to his device and get those videos removed or
something. Okay.
Okay. So, they should know what the reasons were now, and we'll
get into those later, but I was charged in February 2021. And
these charges were then made public in October 2022 after the
accuser contacted my city's local newspaper to run a story about
these allegations before that year's McMaster Hoko was to take
place. During this time, I felt absolute agony. I stopped making
comedy and prank videos because I just, to put it simply, lost
my sense of humor. And it's embarrassing to admit, but I felt
helpless. Now, I want to give you an overview on these things
in society. Through legal counsel and many other stories that
have been shared with me, I've learned that my case is not unique.
False accusations are common and absolutely devastating to the
victims. For those I the funny thing is or not not funny thing
I guess, but he keeps saying false accusation and it's not like
to us it's not a false accusation yet. To him it is, but he's
saying, "Oh, I want to present this in an unbiased way." You
can't tell me it's a false accusation. I'm going to pres present
my false accusation to you in a un as unbiased a way as possible.
That's not possible. You can't do that.
>> Those that don't know, in Canada, there is no actual
evidence required to charge and convict somebody in this type
of crime. In most assault case require,
>> okay, yes, you can be charged with assault without physical
evidence. It does not say you can be convicted. It says you could
be charged without evidence as in we might have to we might charge
you and we might collect additional evidence like a video, like
your testimony, like a bunch of different things, right? This
is not this is not shocking that they would like somebody comes
to the police, they say they say I was raped. They don't have
physical evidence. They just say, "I was
what is going to happen there?" This is, by the way, why when
somebody's charged, you shouldn't treat them like a monster immediately,
unless there's some additional evidence, right? Like, unless
there's some kind of public evidence that's out there, you shouldn't
treat these people like they're monsters because yes, you can
be charged without evidence in Canada or with only testimony.
Testimony is evidence, but physical evidence. Oh, they say physical
>> Yeah. So, this is a differentiation. And yeah, testimony
is evidence. So >> wired to charge and convict somebody
in this type of crime in most >> Wait, that's not what
it's Oh, hold on. Convictions can be made solely on credible
witness testimony if it meets the beyond a reasonable doubt standard.
I would imagine that's the same as every single crime ever.
That's
if if it's proven beyond a reasonable doubt, then you can be
It can be made on w on on witness testimony. I would imagine
it's very very difficult to convict somebody on witness testimony
beyond a reasonable doubt if there's only one witness.
I say I imagine I know that to be the case,
right? Cuz if it's just two people in a locked room and there's
no other evidence at all,
how in the world
do you not have reasonable doubt? Like he would have you believe
that basically they both walked away, they thought it was totally
consensual and then weeks later she makes an allegation, right?
There's no physical evidence. It's just their testimony against
one another. There's no physical evidence whatsoever.
And he is convicted on that. I
no shot. 0% chance unless he showed himself to be lying in court,
right? Unless he totally invalidated his credibility as a witness
somehow. >> Evidence required to charge and convict somebody
in this type of crime. In most assault cases, there isn't actually
any concrete evidence. It ends up just being one person's word
versus another. He said, she said situation. To put it simply,
telling the truth,
>> which is why most assault cases don't end in conviction.
That's just facts, man. Sorry. So, as >> well, sorry, I
that actually might not be facts. Hold on. That might not be
facts. It's possible that they don't prosecute or I would say
most allegations of assault don't end up in conviction. That's
what I should say. I'm guessing if they charge it, they probably
think they have something such that they could actually make
a case. >> As an accused person, the only strategy you
have is to find lies, discrepancies,
contradictions in the accuser's story. So, imagine you or your
loved one is being accused despite there being zero evidence.
If you or your loved one's defense lawyer cannot question the
credibility of the person making these accusations, it will most
likely lead to a conviction, and there's nothing you can do about
it. As much as this system and laws were put into place with
good intentions to help real victims and real survivors, an unfortunate
side effect is that they are highly abusable and exploitable.
They often take years of time, hundreds of thousands of dollars,
and the accused person loses their job, loses their reputation,
and is publicly shamed, and potentially even ends up in jail
for something they didn't do. But aside from that, from the defendant
standpoint, there are also laws that have been put into place
to make it even more difficult to defend yourself. In a normal
trial, you can get access to information such as records, messages,
emails, etc. However, in assault cases, the police and prosecutors
can, and in my case, they did actively redact any and all information
or evidence to prevent you from using it in your defense. So,
in my case, it was brought to our attention that there were thousands
of communication records that had been redacted by the police.
We later found out that the police not only redacted all of this
data, but they actually emailed the accuser and said, "Is there
anything specifically that you would like us to redact?" And
then she replied saying, "Yes, I would like you to redact all
of the emails with my therapist and all of the communications
with her alleged boyfriend and in particular specific emails
that were very, very telling about what actually happened that
night." And I
Okay, now hold on. I Who are the email? Oh, I I can see how this
could be a problem.
I'm trying to think of like how would he have gotten access to
this stuff?
If that's the case, how would he have gotten access to this stuff?
>> I will get into them later on. But anyways, back to
the evidence. At one point, I remember they gave us about 90
different pages and around 80 of them were completely blacked
out. I'm not a lawyer. I'm actually kind of an idiot. But from
what I've been explained by legal counsel, this makes it incredibly
hard to defend yourself at trial. For example, if there is evidence
that we're bringing that contradicts their version of events,
they can change their version of events before trial. So, why
is it like this now? Well, first of all, obviously it's intended
to protect real survivors from privacy concerns as well as trials
being delayed. But what it really is is they essentially wanted
to get more convictions after the 2016 acquitt of John Gomeshi,
which led to significant changes to >> Dude, Gomeshi needed
to be acquitted. I'm sorry. When you see the facts of this case,
the Jean Gomeshi case, it's actually disgusting. You want to
know about like a men's rights likeorgus
board for people? Basically, this guy got convicted and I do
believe the crown possibly knew that there were messages between
two of his accusers ex talking to each other about how they were
going to make this up, how they were going to like just lie on
this guy's name.
And this guy, this guy literally got totally assed.
And he was like a CBC, he was on the radio, he's on Canadian
media here. Frequently referred to as the Gomeshi rules, this
was implemented via Bill C-51 and subsequent legislation, which
are designed to make it easier to secure convictions by altering
how evidence regarding a complainant's credibility is handled.
These changes were meant to counteract how in the Gomeshi trial,
the defense was able to use contradictory evidence like emails
and photos to successfully challenge the credibility of witnesses
and get an acquitt. In summary, because of Bill C-51 and the
Gomeshi rules, if there is evidence that shows contradictions
in the accuser's statement, it can be discarded. And even if
it's not discarded and it is allowed at trial, it has to be given
to them and approved. And that gives them the opportunity to
prepare for it and potentially alter a story. This is what has
been >> how is this I wonder how this is different than
like standard discovery in the US,
right? So now, if the defense has a record that shows the complainant
is lying or misrepresenting evidence, that record must be disclosed
in advance. A lawyer is then appointed for the complainant who
is granted standing to argue for suppression of the defense
In other words, the legislation will tip off a liar that records
exist exposing their lie and then gives them the chance to come
up with an explanation.
I don't know that this is necessarily
bad. I I can see how if you're a defendant, you don't like this,
obviously, right?
But here's the thing. What is the likely outcome of this rule?
Is it that is it that a bunch of defendants who are totally innocent
lose their chance to be like proven innocent? Or is it that like
it's possibly a gray area or you're guilty and you find some
inconsistency in the story and you drum up a bunch of around
that inconsistency such that you basically get let off the hook
for a crime you actually did. It feels like that's the second
one way more than the first one, but I guess we'll have to see
how it was used against him. put into effect to get more convictions.
The problem is it is potentially at the cost of innocent people
going to jail and having their life ruined. Again, I want to
preface. I am not a lawyer, but that is my understanding of the
law, and I'm open to being corrected. Now, right off the bat,
from these statements of the accuser alone, we had many examples
of inaccuracies, contradictions, and story changes. But once
we found out that there was all of this actual evidence that
had been intentionally redacted, we became very curious. After
several years and over $100,000 just in pre-trial application
costs, we were able to get a significant portion of the redacted
evidence, including emails, text messages, etc. After reviewing
them, it was quite clear that there were multiple strong motives
to fabricate these allegations. Now, if we go back to the encounter,
remember that the accuser only actually had an issue with my
attempt to film a consent video. This is what was so confusing
to me because I was there. She initiated with me afterwards and
we continued having all of this material is available in the
official trial trans.
>> I mean that I'm guessing so the the trial transcript
is there. He's got all of his stuff. Okay.
But I'm guessing this is something he gets questioned on like
what do you mean a consent video?
It's not like she told the therapist she was going to lie or
something. I'm guessing what she told the therapist was something
along the lines of I feel this way. This is what happened. Here's
how I feel about it. I'm conflicted. I don't feel like he violated
my consent, but like I also know that when I look at it, when
I sit back and look at it, I like I feel violated. I do think
my consent was violated, but I I don't know if I should make
it an allegation or something, right?
Like I'm guessing because when you talk to your therapist, you're
giving your like internal monologue, your internal like discordant
thoughts.
I could see something like that coming out which you can go over
in the description. But even though I deleted whatever was recorded,
she had a massive concern on whether or not this video still
existed and was worried that >> why would she be concerned
about that?
Wait, this guy
this guy could have engendered like a bunch of goodwill from
me if he just said I'm kind of a scumbag. I pulled my phone out
in the middle of and she caught it and she said delete whatever
you've got and I did and that's why she was like skeptical of
me or skeptical that's what she talks about. But he's go he's
doing the whole consent video thing. That's like such an obvious
lie now. It actually annoys me >> that it would be circulated
online. And we know this because it was mentioned multiple different
times, for example, from the April 18th transcript. And what
about if he actually took a video? If he did and that got out,
that could ruin my entire life. That is from the email she sent
her therapist the night of our date from April 18th. This is
at 2:22 p.m. on August the 7th, 2 days after August the 5th.
Also, I'm going to the police, maybe not to press charges, but
I want to tell them and report it and see if they could do anything
about him possibly taking a video or picture of me. End quote.
My lawyer asked, "You sent this, right?" She responds, "Yes,
my lawyer." Okay, so again, the primary purpose for going to
the police that you are sure you want them to do something about
is to see if he took pictures or videos of you. The accuser?
Yes, lawyer. And in your mind, you would agree that that would
entail them having to at least go to his house, talk to him.
Accuser, yes. And taking his phone. Accuser. Yes. Okay. And then
making sure that there wasn't anything there that you had in
a compromised picture or video, right? Accuser. Yes. If you want
to double check this, this is all in the testimony on April 18th.
>> Okay. Why isn't he showing like her recollection of
events
would be my question here. Why wouldn't you go and say like what
does she think happened?
Right?
Because she might say, "Well, this guy violated my consent in
this way or that way, but like it's whatever. Maybe he misunderstood
or something and I would let it go. But also, he recorded this
video and that sort of shows his his like underlying motives,
his underlying respect for me." And I I do think, you know, I'm
going to make I'm going to say you insulted me when I wouldn't
have before because I think you've got this video as well. I
don't think that's
>> So, when she contacted the police, her concern was to
know for sure that the video was truly deleted. However, the
only way that the police can search a phone is by obtaining a
warrant, and a warrant can only be obtained if there was a crime
from the appeal. Although this factual conclusion was not mandatory
given the evidence, reaching it meant that when the accuser left
Mr. Denmar's home. She believed he possessed a compromising video
of her on his phone, which increased the probitative value of
evidence supporting a potential motive to fabricate. As Justice
Crochenko concluded, the accuser's most significant concern was
that Mr. Densore had images or videos of her on his phone. It
was essential to consider whether the accuser made the assault
allegation partly or fully to prompt police to access his device,
especially since the police apparently would not take action
unless she made a formal complaint. In regards to her email to
the police, she said, "I am unsure if I want to press charges
at this time, but I am deeply concerned as to if he has any photos
or videos of me." Following back and forth communication with
the police, the accuser eventually went in and gave an official
statement nearly two months later. She then described a non-consensual
encounter that, to be frank, did not happen. I'm going to try
and say this as politely as possible. There are multiple points
in the accuser's testimony which contradict her police statements
and her testimony at trial. I want to share a few major discrepancies
and then you can decide for yourself. Now, as a warning, some
of the information I'm about to share is graphic and potentially
triggering, but I must go into these details so that you can
see just a couple of the major discrepancies and inconsistencies
in this person's testimony. I am just comparing her version of
events compared to her other versions of events and her own testimony.
Let's proceed. The accuser testified that I aggressively removed
her shirt and pulled down her dress. In testimony, she claimed,
"He started by removing my shirt and pulling down my dress so
that my breasts were exposed." Then in cross-examination,
she further insisted, "No, he didn't ask me to take it off. He
just started to take it off." My lawyer asked again, "You're
sure about that?" To which the accuser confirmed, "Yes." She
made this allegation in testimony and then doubled down on this
in cross-examination with my lawyer. However, these new allegations
she made in her testimony are totally different from her actual
statement to police to police.
This is like quite regular. By the way,
I don't know if this is
how do I explain this? I don't know if this is necessarily
indicative of something. I would say it's something you weigh
for sure, right? If everything's incoherent, then probably you
weigh this against them pretty heavily. But yeah, there's just
a there's a difference in how your memory works over time. There's
almost no way to unless you
Yeah, dude. Your memory is different over time, >> she
said. So, we went to his room and we were like just sitting on
his bed and he put on a show on Netflix and then he put his arm
around me and then after a few minutes kissed me, which I was
okay with and then he told me like, "Take off my shirt, which
I was comfortable with because I was like wearing a dress underneath
it." So, in her original story, she claims that I politely requested
her to take her shirt off. And
this isn't disconnected at all. Hold on. Wait, what?
She's wearing a dress under the shirt. So, he politely asked
for her to take her shirt off. And she says, "Okay, I'm wearing
the shirt under it." Or, "I'm wearing the dress under it." And
then you pulled down the dress.
Wait, where's the where's the indis where's the uh discrepancy?
>> And she did it herself voluntarily. and comfortably.
However, at trial, she said he started by removing my shirt and
pulling down my dress so that my breasts were exposed. Then in
cross-examination, she further insisted again as part of this
aggressive encounter she's trying to paint. No, he didn't ask
me to take it off. He just started to take it off. My lawyer
confirmed, "Are you sure?" She confirmed, "Yes, that is how it
happened." However, my lawyer then confronted her with her own
original statement to police and he reminded her that this is
what she said and then he asked her again what actually happened.
She then confirmed her original story which is that I asked her
to take her shirt off and she >> Yeah, this is this is
okay. So,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The lawyer said t-shirt and this is just one
of those things. People are not this precise. They're never this
precise. I don't listen I don't necessarily think this means
much but honestly
I'm sitting here I'm like I I don't necessarily think this is
like this amounts to assault yet either right I do not think
in my opinion an escalation in the middle of a consensual encounter
like this like if they were already kissing and stuff I don't
think that's necessarily like a assault okay I think what I'm
seeing there is not necessarily assault I'm guessing it goes
beyond this. Okay. >> He did so voluntarily. My lawyer
further confirmed asking because you're the one that took your
shirt off with his request and that was your way of showing interest
or consenting, right? To which she responded, "Yes,
this is a uhoh. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
So, is he going to try to present that?" Like, again,
nobody's going to deny that she very much went to your house
and wanted to. That's what I said from the very beginning. I'm
never going to deny that because everything, you know, she's
like, "Oh, can you show me your YouTube studio?"
Immediately when you tell me that story, I'm like, "Yeah, this
person just wanted to you that the person thought you were like
a funny content creator. They just want to you." That's what
it was.
It's about how the how the encounter proceeded and the rapy things
you did during this encounter. Okay. So, this would be one of
the things right here pulling the shirt down where I would expect
her to say like no stop or or
if she didn't want that and maybe she doesn't. You've got like
one more escalation after that where if she's not reciprocating
or if something gets weird where I'm like, whoa, what the is
happening, right?
So, we'll see how this story proceeds from her end. Okay. And
with with this guy specifically,
I just think I think the inconsistencies he's shown so far, especially
early on, I'm like, these are totally expected, totally understandable,
right, as you go through this stuff. And I do think we've gotten
indications he's leaving stuff out from her side of the story.
>> Clear example of willingness to intentionally remove
and omit participation and change details to suit the false narrative
of an aggressive non-consensual encounter, which, to put it simply,
just never happened. Moving on. There were fabricated bruises.
The accuser claimed that I aggressively bit her breasts, causing
bruising, swelling, and red marks for days after. On August 6th,
less than one day after our date, the nurse examined her breasts
and found zero bruising, zero swelling, and zero red marks.
This was totally fabricated from the appeal. In her examination
and chief, the accus zero bruising.
>> There were fabricated bruises. The accuser claims that
I aggressively bit her breasts, causing bruising, swelling, and
red marks for days after. On August 6th, less than one day after
our date, the nurse examined her breasts and found zero bruising,
zero swelling, and zero red marks.
this.
I would wonder how quickly after >> was totally fabricated.
>> Let it go >> from the appeal. In her examination
and chief, the accuser described an aggressive sexual assault.
It began when Mr. Densmore removed her shirt and pulled down
her dress, exposing her breasts. She testified that Mr. Densmore
kissed and bit her breasts which was quite painful and that the
biting left bruises and red marks that lingered for two to three
days after their encounter. He then pushed her onto her back,
got on top of her and her digitally. Page 34. Though the events
described above qualify as a violent assault, Justice Crochenko
flatly rejected the accuser's account, noting how it conflicted
with evidence from the nurse.
Wait.
So, I I also was like, okay, well, we're I I don't know. I don't
necessarily think this is like assault yet. If you're if you're
doing this, you might just be a totally
that does this kind of opening up and women go, "Uh, what the
they don't want to you anymore." Sure. Possibly. What happened
after that? Cuz it sounds like right here, like it sounds like
he the judge went, "Oh, I don't really consider this very much.
This whole thing you just gave me inconsistencies on. The judge
also threw out and is not
He flatly rejected her account,
right?
Flatly rejected this part of the interaction. So, you've given
me a bunch of inconsistencies for this part of the interaction,
but clearly that did not lead to your conviction. Clearly the
judge agreed with you that there were inconsistencies and he
did he didn't believe this part or he thought that she was misremembering
this part. Oh, wait. Hold on. This is Justice Crushenko. a different
guy before the trial judge. Oh, in contrast, the trial judge
expressly accepted Mr. Densore's evidence that he had not bitten
SM's breast or digitally for their consent. On both points, Justice
Kchenko concluded that SM's communication of disapproval, disapproval,
or lack of consent did not occur in the manner. Yeah. So, turning
to phase three, Justice Scrochenko rejected Mr. Densor's testimony.
Yeah.
No, this whole thing it feels like is going against her.
So, like you're giving us all these
but the it seems like the judges actually agreed with you that
they it was inconsistent and they didn't consider it very strongly.
They they said it says they rejected it. >> Who examined
the accuser's breasts and found no bite marks or bruising. He
also noted a major inconsistency about digital that was brought
out in
This is another clear example of fabric. >> Oh, wait. I
didn't read that next part and I do need to read that next part
before we continue. Hold on, hold on, hold on. So, the only caveat
to this rejection of SM's evidence was that notwithstanding my
findings that these two incidents did not occur as stated by
the complainant, I do accept the evidence of the complainant
that during the second phase, the complainant was having some
misgivings about how far things had gone and wanted to end the
evening and leave. Okay. So, he's saying that there weren't bruises
and I do like I do accept her testimony or we're going to keep
her testimony in the record that she was having some misgivings
and might have wanted to leave at this point. >> Rejected
the accuser's account, noting how it conflicted with evidence
from the nurse who examined the accuser's breasts and found no
bite marks or bruising. He also noted a major inconsistency about
digital that was brought out in
This is another clear example of fabricating an aggressive non-consensual
encounter as the accusations of bruises, bite marks, and red
swelling for days after were entirely fabricated and confirmed
by the nurse. Not days after, but the next day, August 6th. Next,
in her police statement, she said that I got on top of her aggressively.
And in her description to the crown, she shared detailed allegations
about this without any mention of her participation. In April
17th cross-examination, however, she admitted that after a few
minutes of kissing, she swung her legs over my body and straddled
me before removing her shirt. Straddling as in mounting me, so
sitting on top of my genital area, and grinding her groin area
directly on mine while sitting upright on top of me. She also
said now that she smiled and moaned and that I would remark I
liked it or moan. Again, this shows that she was an active participant
contrary to all of her previous statements. This is from April
17th, 2024.
Next, in a statement to police, she said that she didn't make
a single noise or sound besides
ow. Then, in cross-examination, she admitted to making noises,
moaning, and saying, "I like it." during various stages of activity
to show her consent that she was an active participant from the
appeal. Another inconsistency was the accuser's avow that the
vast majority of the encounter took place in near silence. In
chief, she was a silent recipient of Mr. Densore's advances.
She testified that other than providing her with specific directions,
the only sound made by either party was Mr. Densore calling her
a >> made by either partified that >> wait wait wait
a vow that the vast majority of the sexual encounter took place
in your silence and chief as was silent recipient of Mr. Danbor's
advances she testified that other than providing with her with
specific directions the only sound made by either party was Mr.
Densore calling her [__] In closing submissions,
trial council described SM's initial depiction of an incomprehensible
narrative of a silent movie.
It also seemed to be incomprehensible to SM, who admitted on
cross-examination on multiple occasions, that they were both
moaning and that she was breathing heavily and that she uttered
words like uh she uttered the words, "I like that."
Wait, where did he he did a whole thing where he was saying some
other stuff she said. Where does that come into the the case?
I wonder because he said he said a whole bunch of other stuff
that she
>> Other than providing her with specific directions, the
only sound made by either party was Mr. Densmore calling her
a In closing submissions, trial council described the accuser's
initial depiction as an incomprehensible narrative of a silent
movie. It also seemed to be incomprehensible to the accuser,
who admitted on cross-examination on multiple occasions that
they were both moaning and that she was breathing heavy. This
is his filed appeal, by the way. >> And that she uttered
the words, "I like that." Next, we're going to start talking
about some of the therapist statements. Now, I understand that
therapy is something that is very personal. It's very private,
and a lot of people watching this might be in
>> I don't know.
This might be something that he gets like hurt for in his in
his own appeal, right?
I think
if he's going to produce for a YouTube video
per therapy documents, is that not like some that's got to be
explicitly disallowed. No,
that feels like it's got to be explicitly disallowed. Like you're
not allowed to go on the internet and say, "Oh, actually, here's
all her therapy documents."
that it feels like it's totally unacceptable. But hey, >> so
I'm not using this in any way to try to minimize therapy or discredit
therapists in general. Okay, just want to start by saying that
there were many issues with the statements to the therapist including
inaccuracies given to the therapist by the accuser which led
to the therapist giving very strong opinions and recommendations
which ended up leading to reshape. >> The specific excerpts
in the record should be public. No. Um, I don't know if that
should be public. I don't know if your therapy records should
be public.
I actually don't know if your therapy records should be subpoenaable.
I'm I'm shocked that they were. And if they are subpoenaable,
I think they should be under some kind of seal such that they're
not released publicly.
Like I personally I don't think your therapy records should ever
be subpoenaable. If you can't make a case unless
does Canada not seal court docks?
Yeah. I'm sorry. I just I straight up don't think your your yourrapy
records should ever be something that gets subpoenaed. That's
the whole point of having like dude that's the whole point. Imagine
if your legal records were sorry your your conversations with
your lawyer were subpoenaable,
right? Did she submit them as evidence? I don't know. Maybe if
she submitted them as evidence herself, maybe those would be
fine to put out publicly. Maybe. Maybe. >> What actually
happened in the mind of the accuser in addition to collusion.
And if you don't know what collusion is, Google it because it's
very bad. The accuser was asked about some of these [laughter]
statements throughout the trial. In this particular one from
April 18th, my lawyer. Okay, so you're not very truthful with
your therapist, are you? The accuser? No. I'm extremely truthful
to her. My lawyer. Extremely truthful, right? Accuser. Yes. My
lawyer. That's how you characterize what you're saying to her.
So, this whole thing is just going to be like that between the
therapist and the original police complaint and then her testimony
at trial, there are like very minor inconsistencies that aren't
even real inconsistencies. The t-shirt thing, not even a real
inconsistency, okay? That there are very And by the way, the
bruising thing also led to the judge going, "Well, I actually
don't really take this this testimony seriously. I think it's
not credible."
>> So, the accuser, >> we'll see how it goes. >> Sorry.
I I I can do my own size. Okay. >> Here, in particular,
she made a statement to her therapist where she inaccurately
depicted our date and implied very dangerously that I tricked
her into coming into my house. I debated whether to send this
or not because maybe I'm just being dramatic or stupid or overthinking
or reading into something that didn't happen. Or maybe it just
brought this whole thing on. Dude,
I'm sorry if you
if you can't handle this kind of talk or whatever.
Dude, I I'm going to say something. I'm going to do the benevolent
misogynist thing. This is how women like think and talk all the
time is they like double think themselves all the time. I'm sorry.
This kind of like double thinking on anything can't be read.
Seriously,
I'm sorry.
Women Women literally be like, you know, I I think 2 plus two
is four, but sometimes I wonder. Women be like that. I'm sorry.
I hate to tell you this. Women literally be like that. Okay.
Sometimes I think 2 plus two is four, but you know, to myself,
sometimes I think maybe not. I'm sorry that this kind of like
internal. And by the way, they they know how to not put that
out in the world so that they don't get judged for those like
thoughts in their head. Women have these like self-doubting thoughts
that are totally illogical and totally
but they have them. It's why they don't It's why they don't waste
their lives doing totally like playing League of Legends or something,
right? For their entire life. It's why they don't do that.
No, no, no, no, no, no. Trust me, there are people there are
guys who do this, too. I'm just saying women be like that way
more than guys. There are lots of guys who are like that.
>> On to myself. But I went on a date tonight. We were
supposed to go for a hike and then drinks, but when I showed
up to his house, he said it was too late to go for a walk, so
we started watching a movie. My lawyer asked, "Have I read that
accurately?" The accuser confirms
>> By the way, this has nothing to do with this isn't this
is
thinking this is an
Literally doesn't matter.
It's irrelevant. >> My lawyer and that's not what happened,
is it? Accuser, not all of the details. No, my lawyer. But that's
what you told her happened, right? Accuse her. Yes.
Pause. Inaccuracies like that are super important because they
have a severe impact on the therapist's perception of events,
which leads to responses from the therapist that as a therapist's
responses would give massive influence over the accuser. So,
the therapist receives this amongst other inaccurate statements
continuing from April 18th. So, these are your records that she's
made about sessions that she's had with you. And the session
date is Friday, August the 7th. We spent the session going over
her experience and looking at potential stuck points where she
blamed herself. In reviewing the evening, it is clear the accuser
attempted to make good decisions and that he
was clearly a predator skilled in having her make small changes
to their plans until she was in his apartment.
Have I read that correctly? The accuser confirms yes.
The accuser claims to be extremely truthful to her therapist,
giving a completely inaccurate statement about the date to her
therapist with a very misleading implication. As a result, the
therapist tells her, "Dude,
it's actually way different. They drove like 10 minutes to go
on the hike and then they realized it was too dark and then he
realized it was too dark." Okay. it. It's like it's not like
he said, "Oh, well, it's too late now. We shouldn't go out."
He drove 10 minutes and then they drove back and he was like, "Well,
I guess we could just watch a movie."
With authority, he was clearly a predator, skilled in having
her make small changes to their plans until she was in his apartment.
She then takes these various responses she gets from her therapist
and sends them to her friends and family. Also from April 18th.
Yeah, Dr. therapist said that he seemed very calculated in the
way he acted like he had thought it out and that I'm not the
first.
So now she's giving false information to the therapist. Therapist
is responding and then she's
false. She's she's literally describing a a conflict in her head
where she is thinking well did this guy do something like sort
of I predatory in that he was like intentionally angling for
this to happen or did this just happen and I I'm not for missing
it. This is literally the kind of thing you talk to your therapist
about. And if the therapist decided that like he this guy's a
because of that and only that then that therapist is come on
man. >> So now she's giving false information to the therapist.
Therapist is responding and then she's taking what the >> give
you your first session. >> Therapist is responding and
sending it to her friends using the authority of the therapist.
>> You genuinely want to go for a hike. You don't plan
that for seven. Was it seven in August?
What do you got? An hour and a half of light there tops.
What? What is the sun setting in August? I feel like you want
to be off the trail by the time the sun's setting.
That was not going to be very much of a hike, was it?
>> Although I will argue I will argue, okay, in my head,
I will argue
that if she was going for a hike at 8:00 p.m., she's definitely
down to which, you know, it is what it is.
This is this seems like more of an argument over like am I for
not realizing he only wanted to me?
Dude, this this is this is one of the many messages that the
accuser sent to her friends and family. You can see more in the
May 31st closing arguments. Now, during testimony at trial, her
statement changed. April 12th, you said the tour was approximately
15 minutes, nothing unusual. What happens after that? She answers,
then he suggests that we go for a hike. Oh. Hm. And how did you
then end up going for a hike? What happens after that? He suggested
that we drive to a trail that was close by to his house. So I
agreed to that and we started driving there. So the accuser admitted
that actually I suggested we go for a hike which was the original
plan and then we left the house. Okay. So you described driving
towards the escarment. Accuser. Mhm. Do you eventually stop somewhere?
Accuser. No. He says that it's busy and that we shouldn't bother
going on a hike because it's getting dark out. Going a bit down.
Then what happens? Accuser. So then he suggests going back to
his house. Are you able to give us an estimate about how long
you were trying to locate a hiking trail? Accuser again. Not
long. Maybe
Dude. Dude, come on.
Come on. That is that is a total tactic. Why the Bro, you go
to this guy's YouTube channel. Where's his YouTube channel, by
the way? Where did that channel go? Am I going to hear about
his hike technique? I feel like I'm going to hear about it. I
tell people we're going to go on a hike and then it's too late
and gotcha.
Right. 15 20 minutes. And so did you agree with his suggestion
to go back to his house? Accuser. I did. We then returned to
the house after she agreed to return and watch Netflix and chill.
But literally the same night as the date, August 5th, she then
goes and tells a very different and inaccurate version the same
night. So many implications, opinions, responses, and collusion
and influences were made from these inaccurate statements. And
what's super concerning,
>> collusions were made. Collusions >> about all
this. Aside from that, she never corrected her therapist by saying,
"Actually, he did suggest going for a hike." And then we actually
did leave the house and go to the hiking trail.
>> so this is the second time I'm hearing him explain something
that is not real, right? I was just shooting a consent video
in the middle of that's why I pulled my phone out in the middle
of cuz I was shooting a consent video to show that she was going
I was going to ask her, "Hey, you consent to all of this, right?"
That's all I wanted to do. I definitely wasn't just videoing
me her at all. Right, guys?
And then
uh and now this where it's like no, we really did drive and then
I realized it was too dark and that wasn't planned at all, man.
It was I was just driving out and then we come back. I was just
driving out and then we come back, man. And we only returned
after she agreed to because it was getting dark. Another thing
she never acknowledged, the reason it was getting dark is why
we came back was because she showed up over 30 minutes late to
the date in the first place. So instead of being honest about
this or clarifying it or correcting it at all, she then took
the therapist's responses amongst others and then sent them to
her friends and family members. Objectively speaking, this can
be considered very problematic because she essentially gave an
inaccurate statement to the therapist which then >> I absolutely
hate when uh when what do you call it? Um like PUA types go objectively
speaking based on the data based on Dude, you're not you're not
doing a data driven thing. Stop. Just stop. Just stop it. Okay.
elicits responses based on these false details and then instead
of correcting them, she uses them as authoritative proof that
something happened to her that didn't actually happen. But all
of this was under false pretenses from false information. And
this was not cleared up and corrected until nearly 4 years later
at trial in 2024. at that point all these communications and
the eventual >> well so tenstone basically what he's arguing
is I'm guessing the video recording comes into play significantly
in the transcripts
right and he has explained away that part by just saying I wanted
to film a consent video but he doesn't address it at all and
he seems to like to acknowledge that he started recording it
during this encounter so apparently while this guy is midstroke
he pulls his phone out and he's like hey uh I need a Pause. I
forgot to record this video where you consent. So, could you
get your clothes on? He didn't do any of that. Right.
>> False accusation had already happened. The damage had
already been done because amongst all of the other inaccurate
statements made to the therapist. This completely colored the
therapist's perception of what actually happened, leading to
her convincing the accuser, I was a skilled predator. I've done
this to multiple people. Amongst other things, such as, she's
not the first. as somebody that's never met. >> You literally
I I would bet any amount of money that she's not the first person
you've done this to. I would bet I bet any amount of money that
this is not the first person you've done something like this
to. Not the part, but the oh, I'm going to get you to my house
and I'm going to get you to like I'm going to get you to stick
around to to come inside. I Dude, there's no way. I'm sorry.
This is like 100% you have. >> And knows absolutely nothing
about me. In fact, I'm actually not I'm I'm I would also bet
that you're not the first person. Sure, she's not the first person
you've recorded like this to intentionally put out false information
to someone and then take what they said in response and use that
as an authoritative source to influence friends and family. And
this is just a small taste. I highly recommend you go through
the April 18th testimony. Everything's in there and it is shocking.
Okay, moving on. Next, when giving her original statements to
the police, she said that oral lasted 5 to 10 minutes, but also
that the consent video incident happened about 1 minute into
the oral and then our brief conversation about >> Dude,
who is she was blowing you and then the phone came out?
>> Dude, yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
dude. It's It's actually so rough. Nobody really Nobody thinks
of this. Nobody understands that it's um like
It is though. It is.
Dude, I I'm just It's so [__] up.
It's [__] up cuz people just don't have conversations
about it. This should be a part of said when you're a kid at
this point, right? Like literally explaining to people, "Yeah,
you can't record school encounters. Yeah, I know that you've
got a phone right there that could easily do it. There's no way.
There's no way that you could do that. Oh man, it's crazy. >> It
was approximately one minute long. So this timeline would imply
that oral resumed afterwards to fill up the remaining 3 to 8
minutes. At trial on April 12th, she said that after the consent
video, she immediately stood up and successfully put her clothes
on and claimed that she tried to leave. But then during cross-
examination on April 17th, she acknowledged there could have
been more time for oral studies and it was possible that it continued.
My lawyer. Okay. But then you'll also agree with me that even
after he put his phone away that you continue to engage with
him in oral. Accuser. I don't remember. Lawyer. Okay. Well, let's
talk about timing here because you said the oral lasts between
5 and 10 minutes, right? Accuser. Yeah. >> Hold on. That's
not Oh, 5 and 10 minutes. Okay. Hold on. Maybe. >> Yes.
And the incident with the phone happened about a minute or two
into the oral, right? Accuser. Yes. So therefore, there was more
time for oral accuser. There could have been lawyer. Wait, wait,
hold on. Does that not make sense in both cases? Doesn't that
mean that
Sorry. Couldn't you also read this as there was more time that
she was actually performing oral before she got up and walked
away or before he pulled his phone out? Isn't that equally likely
I would have been about a minute or two into oral. So therefore,
there was more time for oral, right? There could have
>> Is that not Is it not possible that she was responding
like, "Yeah, I could have been blowing him longer before he pulled
his phone out before I noticed or >> for oral accuser."
Dude, the dude, I just want you to realize now, now that we have
the details,
he pulled his phone out for a consent video with his in her mouth.
That was a consent video. He would have you believe, dude.
That's an insane That is an insane lie to start the video with.
A totally insane lie. An absurdity.
There could have been lawyer. Okay, it's possible that it continued,
right? Accuser, it's possible. I'm not even going to say my version
of events, okay? This is her version
versus her own version. This completely contradicts her other
version of events about getting up, putting her clothes on, and
then trying to leave from the appeal. In chief, April 12th, the
accuser testified that once Mr. Densore took out his phone, she
stood up, starting to put her shirt on, looking for her purse.
Remember the purse for later. On April 17th, when trial council
asked the accuser whether she continued to engage with him in
oral after his phone was put away, she claimed that she did not
remember in addition to there could have been time. Upon further
questioning on April 18th, the accuser conceded that it was possible
that she performed additional fellatio following the phone incident.
This is a massive
>> Uh that's I just went back to Reddit. That's your reading.
She didn't concede that it was possible she did it following
the phone incident. She conceded that it's possible it went
That's interesting >> because if oral continued, which
is what actually happened, that would mean all of the things
she said about getting up, putting her clothes on, and trying
to leave was completely fabricated. >> Is that that's his
alleg. [laughter]
>> Look at the transcripts. Moving on. There was further
conflicting evidence in regards to her retrieving and putting
her shirt on. This is from April 18th after my lawyer has been
asking her about when we had and then I asked where the bathroom
was and left the room. Why would you need to ask for the washroom?
He's already showed you where it was before he got to his room.
Accuser, he did. I guess that was my way of telling him I needed
to use the washroom. A little further down. So, you'll agree
with me that according to you, those are the first words spoken
by you or him since you had that little exchange about the phone.
Correct. Accuser. I believe that he did say something when I
was putting on my shirt.
Remember that. I don't remember what it was, but I remember kind
of awkwardly laughing. My lawyer. Okay. So, now you remember
that, right? But you didn't remember it before. Accuser. I don't
remember what he said. I remember not responding to him talking
though. Lawyer. Well, you did. You said you laughed. Accuser.
Yes. Lawyer. So, that was a response, right? Accuser. Okay. Yes.
So, aside from the earlier statements about total silence,
>> dude. Um,
actually, when I said we basically didn't talk, I I did forget
that he made some comment, some quip, and I was like, haha,
I forgot that. Uh, this is lying. >> Which we've gone over.
The inaccuracy here is in her earlier version of events, she
claimed to have stopped oral, stood up, and already had put her
shirt on from April 12th. Accuser, I'm still sitting down. But
when he went to go put his phone down, he had kind of removed
or stopped standing directly in front of me with his feet on
both my sides. So, I kind of had to wait. >> Dude, now
now I'm psyched for the Techone version of this. I got to see
when Tee's watching this. I have to see when when he hears about
the phone coming out and the timing of it. I just got to see
if Tech if that light turns on at all.
Um, she was blowing you. You pulled your phone out. That was
to a consent video, guys. That makes sense, man. Today's society,
right? Today's culture, guys. They got to consent videos while
the woman is blowing them. Just a quick consent video. >> Stand
up and create distance between us. So, I did that and then I
started putting my shirt back on looking for my purse. My lawyer,
did you indeed put your clothes back on? Accuser, I did. But
here on April 18th, aside from the different story about the
oral continuing, there was also a major discrepancy that actually
shows even more credibility towards the oral actually continuing,
which is what actually happened. Because after
had completed, she claimed, "I believe that he did say something
when I was putting on my shirt, but why would you put your shirt
back on if it's already on? If you got up after oral, like you
said in your original statements on April 12th, >> like
I'm assuming what happened was she was blowing him. She went
to leave and then he said some stuff that made her go, "Okay,
maybe it's not that bad." And then they finished the encounter.
I don't think she's I'm assuming she then took her shirt off
again. No. Wouldn't that be what makes sense?
>> He did say something when I was putting on my shirt.
But why would you put your shirt back on if it's already on?
If you got up after oral, like you said in your original statements
on April 12th, then your shirt would have already been on.
Question: Did you leave the bedroom? Accuser: No. He came up
to me, started kissing me, put his fingers inside of me again,
and then kind of quickly pushed me onto the bed so my stomach
was on the bed, and then he lifted my dress up and put his in
me. In this version, she had already put her shirt and clothes
fully back on. There was no shirt removal, but then I came over
and forced her on the bed and her. So on April 12th, the
I I'm not a physicist, so I don't know about the mechanics of
it all. Okay,
I do believe you could somebody in a dress
and a t-shirt, an overshirt without technically having that dress
be off.
>> the shirt is already on for the after getting dressed
and trying to leave on April 18th in addition to the oral continuing.
The shirt was only put on after the while awkwardly laughing
about something I said. So, if you were telling the truth about
getting up and putting your shirt back on after oral, then the
shirt would already be on. These are just
h I'm sorry. I'm actually losing it at the size. the size when
he like finishes reading some
>> The shirt would already be on. These are
>> Why did he leave these in, dude? Why did he leave them
in at all? You could edit those out in post, man. >> A
few of the inconsistencies between her statement to the police,
her testimony, and her cross-examination.
There were many, many more. If I included them all in this video,
it would be several hours long. These inconsistencies,
inaccuracies, whatever you'd like to call them, are not in comparison
to my statements or testimony. All of these things are her word
versus her own word. These are not even taking into consideration
my testimony where I disagree with basically everything she's
claiming. Even being as polite as possible, there is a alarming
pattern of changing stories. >> contradicting and even
fabricating physical evidence to depict an aggressive encounter.
>> Where's the fabrication of physical evidence? Hold on.
Where's the >> That simply didn't happen. There are dozens
of instances from this person that clearly lower their credibility
or to be blunt outright disqualify their credibility. And to
put it simply,
that is what reasonable doubt is. What started as a concern about
a potential video needed a description of a non-consensual aggressive
encounter in order to get a warrant to access my phone. And the
accuser herself conceded during cross-examination that many points
in her initial statement were not true. I stated this earlier,
but it needs to be said again. The accuser was encouraged to
go forward by her friends, family, and therapist. The issue though
is that she told her therapist as well as her friends and family
not what actually happened. Inaccurate information and that became
the narrative that I was some kind of a
so well the inaccurate information is about how she ended up
in the room.
Dude, it's if I'm I got to assume that if she was ever inaccurate
about her like getting annoyed and going up to leave and then
him basically grabbing her and putting her back down in the bed
and then continue to her. If there was ever any concern about
that,
wouldn't that be what he leads with? I feel like that would be
what he leads with here.
Am I crazy?
because it's all inconsistencies around basically like how the
date started and then how he started filming
and what else when she got outraged and walked away. I don't
know. I I'm guessing the the court transcript,
especially the end will be quite interesting once we go over
that. But we got to get through the video. >> And amongst
the many other inaccurate statements and downright things that
just didn't happen that were shared with the therapist is what
led to the therapist encouraging her to go forward with charges.
And there's a lot more on that that I'm not going to get into
in this video cuz I don't want to get myself in trouble. But
it's crazy. Bottom line is this encouragement was based on incomplete,
inaccurate, and fabricated information. The pressure then accumulated
substantially into several other motives from the appeal. In
the months following their encounter, the accuser faced extensive
pressure from her friends, family, and therapist to press charges
against Mr. Denmore. According to her therapist, Mr. Densore
was a predator who was skilled in making small changes to their
plans until she was in his apartment and had >> I feel
like that's just that that therapist is just showing that they
are like apt at reading information.
That that therapist is correct. >> Likely done this before.
The accuser received similar feedback from her friends, mother,
and stepfather who despite never meeting Mr. Densmore, their
only idea about me, by the way, is my crazy YouTube videos. So
you can imagine what that looked like. Dude, I'm starting to
understand why that YouTube channel isn't there anymore. Is there
like an archive of his YouTube videos? What the were you saying
in your YouTube videos, man? >> Despite never meeting Mr.
Danmore told her that she needed to press charges against Jack
because otherwise she was letting him do that to other girls.
>> By the way, he's highlighting this stuff, right? He's
highlighting this stuff from his own appeal that he wrote. This
is not like a judge's testimony or something. This is his own
appeal that he wrote. This pressure culminated in the accuser
admitting to feeling guilty that if she didn't take any legal
type of action, she would be responsible for him doing this legal
type of so told her that she needed to press charges because
otherwise she was letting him do that to other girls. Uh so she
felt guilty. Dude, this isn't saying you didn't do it. It's saying
she doesn't want the stress of going through a trial or something
and that other people were like, "You should because he will
do this again."
That's not that's not
that's not being pressured like unjustifiably.
She's saying, "I'm just going to take this on the chin." Okay?
I'm going to take this on the chin. I'm going to go about my
life cuz this is too much pressure. This is too much anxiety.
It by the way is a decision women make quite often. Okay?
And this guy's like, "Well, she basically people were like, no,
don't take this on the chin. Then he could rip again." And he's
like, "This is totally unjustifiable. This is a pressure campaign
against her to sue me. Totally
>> Action. She would be responsible for him doing this
to other girls.
>> Cross-examination of the accur.
>> He just makes the face. Uh-huh. No. No other comment.
He just lets it sit in silence for Is it still Oh, it's still
>> Cross- examination of the accuser. Trial transcripts,
April 2024.
>> Moving on. In addition to these factors, there was another
major issue with this person's credibility. In multiple private
emails with her therapist, this person admitted to making her
entire story up. I legally cannot share the full emails, but
it's in her testimony and she confirmed multiple times that these
emails were read correctly, accurately, and that she did say
these things.
All right. So, after blank, so you you write to blank at 1 11:44,
even hours after, not only are you unsure about whether you want
to press charges, but you're not now even unsure whether you're
making this up, reading into something that didn't happen, or
that you're being dramatic, or that you're overthinking. Do you
agree with that? Wait, what is she making up? Hold on. Is this
Wait, what part is she making up? Cuz I thought this was about
how they got there, right? I thought this part, not necessarily
the forcefulness, but I thought this was Oh, no.
And you said that in your evidence that that's how you felt after
he told you to leave after. Do you deny that now? No. And when
Blank emails you back the next following morning, she says, "Actually,
let's pull that up. >> This is all available. I'm excited
to go through this now. I'm excited to go through all of this
>> as well as highlighted in closing arguments on May 31st.
This was particularly devastating for me, my friends, and my
family to have to sit through. And this is why I'm so shocked
that I even had to go to trial in the first place because
that statement to a therapist of of uncertainty is absolutely
not in any way dispositive of you insulting her. I'm sorry. It's
not.
And uh this is why this is why you shouldn't allow therapist
notes to go to court, right? Unless unless the therapist says
I have to I have to leak this stuff because I know a crime has
occurred. I uh
>> there was >> But maybe maybe it gets worse than
that. Maybe it's way worse than that. We'll >> And the
person to have that reasonable doubt was her. Now, as somebody
that has been a victim of assault myself, I know what it's like
to feel like you're in denial about what happened to you. And
you do have thoughts like, "Am I making this all up?" Right?
But this is so much more than that.
okay. Hold on. He just pulled it back a little bit that like,
hey, uh, therapist, dude, I guarantee you that's that is a third
party. That is somebody else telling him, "By the way, this can
happen and you here's how you should present it." I don't believe
for a second that this guy's capable of actually thinking this
like oh well sometimes people think maybe I am just making it
up that that's a normal thing >> and you do have thoughts
like am I making this all up right but this is >> I just
I feel like there's no
and remember credibility is essentially the only available thing
for the defense to question in a he said she said trial with
no evidence. So if changing your story numerous times, potential
collusion from therapists and others influencing you, admissions
of potentially making your >> Dude, I I feel like So what
I suspect here is that his testimony
is quite bad or his cross-examinations are quite bad somehow.
I think that's got to be where the hole is because what he's
describing this pattern, even as he's describing it, I don't
think he's described something that he could be convicted of
beyond a reasonable doubt. I'm guessing there are messages from
him. There are comments from him. There's something going on
here with him
that the judge went, "Oh, yeah, you're Cuz to me, if it's literally
just he said, she said, and he's like left out some stuff
I was talking to your therapist. Collusion. It's not. There's
something going on here, right? The phone thing is already bad.
Yeah. But I I do think I I don't know in Canada if you can make
that assault. It It kind of is. It's altering the agreement like
under which the consent was given. But
it is assault. I just don't know if legally it's handled that
way. So for me, I don't see how they convicted him beyond a reasonable
doubt here. Unless Unless the phone thing could escalate something
to a assault cuz if the phone thing escalates it like to me his
story is so
it's hilariously
false. It's hilar It's like a hilarious lie. It's like a kid
with cookie with like chocolate smeared all over their face being
like, "I didn't take anything out of that cookie jar." Hey kid,
did you take the last cookie? No. No. He's got chocolate like
literally in his eyebrows. No, I didn't take I didn't take the
cookie [laughter] out. Dude, shut up. >> Story ups of a
video and other multiple motives to fabricate as well as direct
evidence of fabricating physical evidence and for lack of better
words, a continuous inability to recall basic facts and testify
credibly isn't reasonable doubt, then what even is reasonable
doubt? Seriously, if this isn't reasonable doubt, then what is?
What can anybody in this position do if
>> He's just focusing on the inconsistencies in her testimony,
man. I
I could tell I could just tell
his choose to >> here. Hold on. Hold on. This is actually
what Think Before You Sleep did, right? When he made his video
on Pingchu, he just focused on inconsistencies in her testimony.
He never took a look at all
at the Techone testimony and how bad it was. Right. like you
just pull out the microscope and focus on the woman instead of
realizing like, oh, if you zoom out, there's two participants
here. What did the other guy say? Well, that other guy sounded
like a total.
Okay, let's take a look at the comments. She got caught lying
to law enforcement multiple times and they still convicted him.
That's insane. People make false accusations in prison. Now,
I will say Tech took a look at this yesterday, so I'm guessing
some of these will be high up. How the can a therapist testify
to something they never even witnessed?
the accuser contact. Well, I'm assuming they're testifying as
to the what what the accuser said to them. Those accusations
should have the same legal legal repercussions for the accuser.
I don't think this is a false
It sounds like she was saying she didn't trust herself to like
have recollected it correctly, right? But it doesn't seem like
it's a false accusation. In fact, she was like having doubts
about it. She was having doubts about whether or not to go through
with it. That means you're like weighing
the decision, right? It doesn't mean you're not sure you Sorry.
It can mean you're not sure you were assaulted, but it it doesn't
mean that you weren't assaulted. It means you're like actually
thinking about this whether or not it's like worth it to do it,
whether or not you truly believe it. You're not just like getting
emotional about something and and committing instantly. It's
like an actual weighing of facts or how you your recollection,
I >> Ignore all of that. Think about if what was happening
to me was happening to you or your partner or your brother, your
sister, your dad, your friend, and then go over everything. Is
there a lack of credibility? And if so, is this lack of credibility
enough for reasonable doubt? As you will read in the transcripts,
there were multiple motives to fabricate. We concluded that the
main one was she thought I still had a photo or video of her
and for whatever reason thought that I was actually going to
post it online. It goes without saying I would never post, publish
or share a consent video online. That would not only be a gross
violent
video, [laughter]
dude. He's talking about revenge board. I would never post revenge
board, but he's still calling it a consent video. Why wouldn't
you post a consent video?
Wait, why wouldn't you do that? >> Violation of personal
privacy, but it would literally be a crime and career. And there's
absolutely no reason for me to ever do that. With that being
said, if I'm being very objective and very polite here, I can
maybe kind of understand the potential worry that they had that
I would during the trial. This person acknowledged that she was
familiar with my videos and she even described them on April
17th as the subject matter was about drinking, interviewing girls,
hitting on girls despite most of my videos being pranks that
had nothing to do with these things. With that being said, the
video >> wait when when's the timeline? Had you had you
just switched it up into being like a pickup artist? was in before
McMaster Hoko 2019, which is essentially a 45 minute satire documentary
about a massive street party where I'm wearing a crown and shotgunning
beers with fans. And in that video, it's a bunch of interviews
about drinking, partying, day kills, and that kind of thing.
So, anecdotally, that was the only experience she had of being
in a previous video of mine. Upon arriving at my house, she texted
her friends saying, "I think it's a joke. I think he's going
to prank me." So, it seems like even before meeting me, there
was an anxiety that there was somehow a possibility of being
pranked. And of course, I had no idea of this. Anyways, from
2017 until 2021, I was known for posting wild party content on
my social media that some considered very vulgar and controversial.
I've even gone to events like Pride and done interviews with
like dozens of naked people and I always made sure to censor
every potential in dozens of naked people and I always made sure
to censor every potential inappropriate thing. With that being
said though, I filmed hundreds of these videos where I would
go and I would do pranks, interviews, especially interviews at
nightclubs and many people face >> Wait, are the are the
pranks like pranks he does where he also asks for a phone number
at the end of it? Is that like the end of the prank? Can I get
your phone number though? Is that
He keeps calling them pranks, but when was he asking for >> severe
repercussions just from appearing in my videos? Multiple videos,
guys and girls were exposed for cheating on their partners. And
this is why I started filming these consent videos when I would
do pranks. Because essentially, if you film a video, like a prank,
you would go up to the person afterwards, be like, "Hey, my friend's
over there. He's filming. This was all a prank. Is it okay if
we use this clip for YouTube?" And you ask them this because
if they say yes, then you're allowed to post it online, right?
And if you don't, they could potentially decide later, oh, I
don't want that clip online. And then they can report the video
and get it taken down. And this can result in you losing your
YouTube channel. If you have a brand deal with the video, you
can lose thousands of dollars. And also, you're not trying to
like humiliate this person online and ruin their lives. So that's
why as pranksters, we go up and we get consent videos. Interview
videos are a little different because when you speak into a microphone,
it's implied consent. So, you don't need to get consent. This
is why I would have so many videos of people saying ridiculous
things. Then they would end up getting in a lot of trouble and
they try to get the videos removed, but it's like, dude, you
shouldn't have spoken into a
>> And when he took his consent video, she was sort of
in a way speaking into a microphone. No, no, >> in a video
at a nightclub. Right. So, this happened for years. And this
is actually what gave me so much anxiety. And as my channel got
bigger and bigger, I started butting heads with the city, with
the universities, with the newspapers. And when I would do my
Hoko videos, multiple students were suspended from sports teams,
and even fined thousands of dollars by the government just for
appearing in my videos. Literally. I know that this is not what
this video is about, but I really want to hammer this point home,
guys. On one occasion in particular, I filmed interviews and
it went viral and then it circulated around that town and three
people ended up getting fired from their jobs. Three people because
they said vulgar things into the microphone which I thought were
just harmless funny things to say. This was in 2019. So, as much
as I'm just like a young guy having fun doing funny making videos
that were meant to be entertaining and fun on occasion there
were real consequences for people and I never wanted that. This
is why I would make sure >> what what is he even talking
about right >> to get consent because not only do I not
want to get things taken down or potentially sued, but also I
don't want to ruin people's lives for the sake of content. And
at a certain point, I started to feel this every time I was filming
prank videos. And I moved away from pranks and interviews entirely.
And I started making self-development content on a completely
new channel. I wanted to focus [laughter] on self-improvement
and actually helping people and writing.
Dude, how a man becomes cold-hearted.
Stop. Hold on. What is the channel called?
Is this gone or is it still there? Dating advice for a 23-year-old
traditional girl.
Is this still there? I might want to go watch this new channel.
I wanted to focus on self-improvement and actually helping people
and writing before I moved off of YouTube and into making movies
because that's my long-term goal, acting and making movies. With
all that being said, being featured in a prank or a hokco video
or an interview is still a totally different thing than having
an intimate consent video published online. It's never happened
before and it never will. On May 28th, we tried to >> an
intimate consent video.
Bro, how much revenge? Sorry, how much like non-consentual is
this guy recording?
Dude, what? I'm shocked. Tell me that nobody else has come out
and said this guy recorded them during
I feel like there has to be some woman who came out at some point
while this was being published in like newspapers and in Ontario.
Somebody had to have come out and gone, "Yeah, this guy did it
to me, too. This guy's a real piece of No, check his >> introduced
these as evidence at trial to show clear examples to the judge
of what a consent video is because that's what we were concerned
that this judge would have no idea what we were talking about.
My lawyer even showed one of these videos. Two. >> Wait,
what was his goal? His goal is $500. He's raised $390 Canadian.
Dude,
that's weak. That's weak. And 100,000 views in the video. $390
Canadian. >> To the prosecutor, the crown. After seeing
it, he fought even harder to make sure that it was not allowed
to be introduced as evidence. The judge then decided not to allow
us to use any consent videos as evidence at trial. But then at
the same time, in closing arguments and the eventual judgment,
both the crown and the judge dismissed the legitimacy of consent
videos being a real thing. The judge even said, "I reject the
evidence of the accused that he was making a consent video, whatever
that really is." And I'm going to be really that he
uh, on this specific point, it is he Why is he reading this part?
On this specific point, it is very odd that the accused would
contemplate making a video to confirm consent after the start
and during oral without first obtaining consent of the complainant
to do so. This explanation and rationale for this was simply
too incredible to believe. I reject the evidence of the accused
that he was really that he was making a consent video, whatever
that really is, or that he told the complainant that he was trying
to film one. This evidence seemed to have just been made up by
the accused in order to justify and explain away his intro the
introduction of his cell phone at this point of his intimate
encounter with complainant. That's what literally everybody thinks
by the way. That's what literally everybody thinks. And and now
he introduces this to you and says, "Actually, guys, actually,
just so you know,
the judge doesn't even believe consent videos are a real thing.
No, he doesn't believe you cuz you're obviouslying lying.
What? What? He was making a consent video, whatever that really
is. And I'm going to be really, really careful with my words
here cuz I want to say this in the most respectful way possible.
Okay? It's very important to consider if the person making these
literally lifealtering decisions should be someone who understands
these type of things and in particular this extremely recent
cultural moment that we are >> Dude I it's going to be
about the phone. It's going to be because of the phone and it's
going to be obvious that this guy is lying the whole time.
I I actually totally believe that he now this lie. By the way,
all he would have to do is just be honest about what you were
doing. But this weird lie, bro. Also, what were the consent videos
he's going to introduce into evidence?
Does he does he literally
uh
I Dude, I don't I I I it baffles me. It baffles me. >> We're
all currently going through, especially back in 2020. >> When
did he start recording the video? by his own admission while
she was blowing him. He pulled his phone out and then he said
this was just to record a consent video getting like showing
evidence that she consented to the encounter and not to film
the encounter itself. It's unbelievable
in a postmeto era. I'm not saying this to discredit judges, okay?
Most judges are legitimate brilliant, like super geniuses. That's
why there's so few judges because it's incredibly hard to do.
So, while being as respectful as possible, what I'm saying is
that my generation, it's different now. We live in an era of
mass surveillance, media, police body cams, consent videos, social
media fame, cancel culture, in addition to hookup culture. There's
a lot going on and it is incredibly confusing to navigate this
world as a young person, especially as a public figure, which
is under increased scrutiny, with your reputation and protecting
that. I am now so excited for Tee's reaction to this because
you know Teone is going to 100% believe this guy even though
he's obviously lying the whole timeation because we all know
what happens if somebody gets any kind of accusation made about
them. Your career in life is basically over. And even if this
disconnect is very minor, it's still a strong enough disconnect
to potentially influence situations like this where an innocent
person can get wrongfully convicted. This is even more important
if the person making those decisions is not actually required
to explain in detail how they even came to these decisions and
whose decision and judgment is then expected to be deferred to
with absolute authority. So for me, despite having evidence of
these consent videos, they were considered inadmissible at trial
and then at the same time used as an argument to lower my credibility.
This was incredibly frustrating.
And again, I'm getting a little emotional here. Let me try and
dial it back. Filming a consent video is not a crime and is not
what I was charged with. However, this person was concerned about
a video of them potentially being put online. And then in the
pretty sure what you're referring to as a consent video is literally
illegal to film.
It's obviously illegal. The thing you're talking about, not not
the act of before going, "Hey, we both consent to this, right?"
That's something you could do. Do like a before and after video
or something if you really are psychotic.
But like,
but like come on. >> Evidence there's a strong motive.
They fabricated an assault in order to prevent a video of them
potentially in their mind being put online despite the fact that
I never have done that and I never would do that. The accuser
also texted her friends saying, "I just realized my biggest dream
in life is to intern at Saturday Night Live. even though that
will never happen because I don't have the skills or connections.
She said that right before coming to my house. That's from the
April 16th document. But I'll let you read the transcript. So
Oh, that's amazing, dude. What? I'm sorry. I got some bad news
for you, buddy.
You two have the same problem. Okay. You want to star in movies?
You want to be an actor? You two have the same problem.
Ow. Unlucky. Unlucky. >> Come to your own conclusions.
To put it simply, in a case that basically only comes down to
credibility, there were multiple statements, changes in details,
contradictions, proven fabrications of evidence that should have
absolutely been taken into account in terms of credibility. And
again, I'm talking about her testimony versus her statement to
police, versus messages to her friends, versus emails to her
therapist and all the things she admitted in them. This entire
time is her word versus her own word. And within her own word,
there are major
major issues. This case is very unique in a sense. There is more
evidence that this person is not a credible witness, made a false
accusation, fabricated evidence with motive and admission of
some of these things than there is evidence that I even assaulted
this person and there is no evidence because I didn't. There
was no assault. It was a consensual
Testifying is terrifying. You're being accused of such a heinous
thing and then having to explain intimate details in front of
your girlfriend, friends, your family, and reporters who are
taking your words out of context and putting you in the front
page of the newspaper, making claims about you in front of literally
your entire city. In my case, >> dude, this you should
be put in the
You I'm sorry. you are a threat.
Possibly not as ater. I I haven't read all the testimony, so
I don't know why they found against him because as he's laid
it out, they wouldn't have. Okay. But you're absolutely a threat.
This was total.
Like the consent video thing is total. The non-consentual recording
is like and your explanation for it is frankly offensive that
you think you could sell this to people >> is in Hamilton.
Half a million people plus Toronto newspapers. So we're talking
like millions of people. So despite all this pressure, you also
have to try and remain calm and not emotional. But at the same
time, you
>> I want to see Hold on. I I looked him >> YouTuber
was sentenced to three. >> Let's see what they say about
this in the uh >> news behind bars today for assaulting
a McMaster student back in 2020. Up until just one day ago, Jack
Densore was posting on one of his YouTube channels to hundreds
of thousands of subscribers. Kelly Battello has more. One day
ago, Jack Densore was uploading his latest video to YouTube.
>> Denmo social. >> As long as you have one or two
friends or people that believe in you, then that's all you actually
need to accomplish the things that you want to. >> Today,
he was take >> the Denmo social chorus, guys. You can get
a chorus one-on-one coaching from this guy
about the chorus. Okay, hold on. Hold on. I keep saying chorus
instead of course. About the course. Uh, I am not some gimmicky
pickup artist or dating coach. What I am is a video creator that
talks to people for a living. I've been to college, university,
and worked in multiple industries before becoming a YouTuber.
Over the last four years, I've filmed over 200 videos where I've
met and talked to thousands of people.
There are dozens of flashy, creepy, cringy pickup courses out
there. Misleading information to teach you game, all of this.
I'm teaching you how to be social. He's not a pickup artist.
He's just teaching you how to be social.
Damn. Wow. He's so cool, guys. AH, IT'S HIM AND JORDAN PETERSON.
WHAT UP? It's him and JBP. Let's go. That's a That's a lovely
drawing you've got there. I I really like that. It's quite something,
you know. That's quite something. I Dude, I put out a voice and
I sound further away. >> into jail after a judge sentenced
him to 3 years behind bars for assaulting a young woman in 2020.
>> Hey guys, welcome back to my channel. Today, I'm looking
for a back to school girlfriend. Densore rose to internet fame
with videos of him attempting to pick up women on university
campuses.
>> Reban Rubin donated $3. What course does he teach? Assault
him once. Denmore 101. >> Wait. Assault him once. Denmore
101. Not one of your finest, Ruben Ruben. Thank you very much
for the donation.
>> Uh, no. We've not done the Dioro thing >> Interviewing
drunk people at H Village and partying with students. More recently,
his content has shifted to him giving men advice. >> In
this video, I'm going to teach you how to attract women.
>> What's up, boys? So, everybody's been through a dry
spell at some point. I'm going to tell you a story about how
I overcame a dry spell I had in the past. >> Listen, man.
Women are much more attracted to you than you are aware of. >> In
2020, Densore was on a first date with a McMaster University
student when they became intimate. At first, it was consensual
until Denmore pulled out his phone to start recording. Densore
argued he was recording a consent video while the woman said
it was his attempt to make a video. Densore then had forced intercourse
with the woman
assaulting her. The judge decided the judge reiterated today
that a assault is a very serious act of violence, one that requires
a penitentiary sentence. Although he did take into consideration
that this is Densore's first offense. >> Mr. Densore maintains
his innocence. His family maintains his innocence.
>> Dude,
why do lawyers in my country dress like that? It looks so goofy.
You look so goofy. Don't. Oh, why? Why? >> I maintain his
innocence. >> Densore's lawyer, Mark Fammy, says the conviction
will be appealed. The notice of appeal has uh already been filed
with the court of appeal and we are >> I don't think this
is necessarily like part for the course. I do think you I think
you do this but I I don't think you're forced to do this as a
lawyer in Canada, right? I think it's just like kind of part
for the course. You're expected to sort of I I don't think it's
required, but I don't know. I don't know right from wrong on
this. I I actually don't know. >> Awaiting a decision about
bail uh pending appeal. Densore is facing another charge of assault
in an unrelated case involving a different woman. That trial
is pending. >> Wait, what? >> Assault in an unrelated
>> uh pending appeal. >> Densore is facing another
charge of assault in an unrelated case in >> I'm defeated,
boys. I'm undefeated. I knew for a fact. I was like, dude, it's
there it is. There it is. Yes, he does look like Rayod to me.
Yes, I agree with that. I it was so obvious that he would have
another one. I wonder if there's another allegation in that other
case that uh that he pulled out his phone to >> involving
a different woman. That trial is pending. Kelly Batello, CHCH
News.
>> Can't wait to appeal. Oh boy. Sorry. I just remembered
this guy with his gun. I just remember this guy. I He was brought
up in he his image was conjured into my mind.
Okay. All right. >> Feel like you're having a heart attack
and you have just immense anger about even being in this whole
situation. So the whole thing was frustrating, gaslighting, anxietyinducing.
It was just [__] terrible. And I'm sure it was terrible
for the accuser as well. Okay. But with that being said, that
does not make it even remotely okay. What she did was wrong and
has had massive consequences for my life that I'm still dealing
with years later. I literally felt like my life was taken from
me. And even on that day, seeing my girlfriend, my friends, my
family collapse to the floor, balling their eyes out. This pain
was and still is truly indescribable. So, in the appeal, you
can read my appeal lawyer's technical assessment why the judge
was incorrect. As a layman, he basically allegedly took the date
and then he divided it into several different boxes. Okay? So,
he took the date and he's like, "Here's the whole thing. Box,
box, box, box." And then he said, "Well, she's not credible in
this box or this box or this box, but I believe her in this box."
again. They're kind of >> That's Yeah, that's not shocking
to me. Somebody that's that's literally how it should be. I'm
sorry. That is actually how it should be >> allowed to
just use their own discretion and decide whatever they want.
But the reason that there was a technical error in this that
allowed us to even appeal in the first place is that if somebody
while testifying makes major inaccuracies, major contradictions,
fabrications, discrepancies in several areas, this should significantly
affect their credibility overall. And this was not done any.
>> No, no, no.
That would make it so that if there was some inconsistency that
had nothing to do with this assault that you were like not even
it's not even in dispute. It's irrelevant. That's what you want
is, hey, if I can point out that she like she said her shirt
was the wrong color one day, uh, I should be able to focus on
that and it should make her not credible. No, it shouldn't. It
would have to be
you would have to point out where that actually tangibly affects
this assault
You would have to do that. Any lack of credibility, especially
a substantial overwhelming lack of credibility in the majority
of areas is reasonable doubt. And if that isn't considered reasonable
doubt, then what is reasonable doubt? It basically makes it impossible
for you or your loved ones to defend yourself as an accused person.
This is how the law works. This is just how it is. This is why
people film consent videos. >> I swear to I swear to God,
this consent video like lie that he's doing.
I feel like this actually contributed significantly to him being
found guilty. Like him trying to defend himself on this actually
leads to him being found guilty in my mind. They go, "Oh yeah,
you are just totally full." Like I you are just like a like the
idea that just tell the truth, man. >> In the first place.
>> This is crazy. The only hope I have at getting my life
back is that we can get a retrial to address these inconsistencies.
But first, it needs to be approved by the appellent court. They
don't give me notice really when they've decided and I actually
have to turn myself into custody and then once I'm already in
custody, they email my lawyer and tell them the decision they've
made. So, I have no idea what's going to happen, when it's going
to happen. I'm just in this really up place right now and it's
terrifying. With that being said, an appeal is a lot different
than a normal trial. I thought it was like, hey, like look at
all this evidence. You know what happened here? But it's not
an appeal is not to retry the case or review the evidence. The
appeal process is for an appeal lawyer to find technical errors
in the judge's decision. With that being said, the way that the
laws work in Canada in these types of trials anyways, trial judges
essentially have complete power to make convictions like this.
Therefore, overturning a wrongful conviction is a nearly impossible
thing to do. I'm just going to be honest. Whether the appeal
is good or not, the default position of the appellent court is
to just defer to the original trial judge's decision regardless
of the evidence because again, they're not supposed to ret. So
if he wait so what I'm guessing again here is what he wants is
well they put them in these different boxes and her inconsistencies
in box one that are not about the assault those should actually
contribute to non-credibility for the assault and the judge basically
will you find do you find an error in that decision-m like boxing
these things up temporally
do you think that's wrong and a lot of judges are I I'm pretty
sure going to go no I don't think that's wrong I think that's
the correct thing to do. And then he's
>> But again, you're going to need more than just his word
on whether or not an assault happened. And I'm guessing this
consent video thing is central. It's like you were recording
and you don't even deny that you were recording that video without
her consent. While she was while she was sucking your you pulled
your phone out to record and you do not deny this. That will
give basically everybody will assume, okay, I assume she's going
to leave after that. And then the story is that you violently
assaulted her while she was trying to leave. Right? That's
>> uh the fact that another woman isn't going to help is
accusing him isn't going to help. That I don't think that can
be considered actually. I think especially when that's not even
litigated yet. I don't think that can even be considered at all.
In fact, I think they probably tried to prevent anybody on the
jury from even finding out about that.
So anyway,
>> yeah, I I'm guessing that they'll find it totally credible
that she would get up and walk away when he's recording. And
then basically
at that point, what did he say about the interactions from that
point? And I'm guessing his insistence of the lie made him seem
noncredible in that moment. And then
>> we'll see. We'll see. I guess cuz I again it feels very
>> I guess again on her side
>> she went to the doctor the next day did she get like
did she plan to accuse this guy like the next day? Cuz if that's
the case I wonder
>> it sounds to me if she went to the doctor the next day
and then she was contemplating whether or not she should file
charges. It sounds like she thought she was right away. >> Oh,
she got a kit. Okay, so she went to the next day and got a kit.
Like that's pretty clear that nobody convinced her that she was
raped. Okay, the idea that she was yaslit into saying she was
totally false, totally fake. Okay, now let's go ahead and
let's grab his website here. This is the website. Trial transcripts,
appeal information. The accused stands charged with one count
of assault against blank the complaintant. The trial was conducted
without a jury. We have returned today for my decision. The basic
legal principles are such so interesting. Not even a jury trial.
Huh? The basic legal principles are such that the accused entered
his trial presumed innocent. The burden of proof was and continued
throughout the trial to be on the crown to prove guilt beyond
a reasonable doubt. That evidentiary burden never shifted. The
accused was not required to prove anything. In charged in the
charged offense of assault, the crown was required to prove each
of the following essential elements beyond a reasonable doubt.
That Jack Densore touched blank directly or indirectly. that
the touching by Jack Densmore was intentional, that the touching
by Densmore took place in circumstances of a sexual nature, that
consent was not present at the time the touching in question
took place. So, so basically that they had a encounter, and that
consent was not present at the time. I'm guessing the the element
D here is going to be mostly fulfilled by the fact that he was
recording the sexual encounter, right? They didn't do a hike
at all, Find. In fact, they went they drove halfway to going
on the hike and turned around and then she agreed to just watch
a movie at his place.
I can't imagine just unimaginable disappointment. Okay. The complainant
and the accused both testified at trial.
The accused was not required to testify, but he elected to do
so. His testimony needed to be assessed like the testimony of
any other witness. The court could accept all part or none of
Mr. Densor's evidence. If the court believed the testimony of
the accused that he did not commit the offense charged, the court
would not find him guilty. If the court did not believe his testimony
of the the did not believe the testimony of the accused, but
was left with reasonable doubt about an essential element of
the offense charged, the court would find him not guilty of the
offense. Even if the testimony of Mr. Densore did not raise a
reasonable doubt about his guilt or about an essential element
of the offense charged, if after considering all of the evidence,
the court was not satisfied beyond a reasonable doubt of his
guilt, the court would not find him guilty of the offense. In
assessing the evidence and determining how much or how little
of the testimony to believe or rely on, the court was required
to assess the credibility and reliability of the witnesses. Credibility
having to do with the witness's truthfulness and reliability,
referring to accuracy of the witness's testimony. It is important
to note that a witness whose evidence on an issue is not credible,
could not give reliable evidence on the same point. However,
credibility is not a substitute for reliability where a credible
witness would still pro provide unreliable evidence. In short,
this court was required to assess all the evidence while retaining
an overriding discretion to decide how much or how little of
a testimony of any witness to believe and or to reply to rely
upon. Before proceeding to the analysis of the evidence, the
defense raised the potential of collusion and argued that because
the complainant
had been in contact with family, friends, and specifically her
therapist following the evening at Mr. Densor's home that she
was influenced by them to such a degree either consciously or
unconsciously that had colored or tainted her interpretation
of the impuged events. So this was the defense they did. Okay.
The defense relied on supportive communications exchanged between
the complainant and her immediate family and friends after the
alleged assault that encouraged the reporting of the incident
to the police that tended to demonize the accused. Additionally,
the defense relied upon communications from the complainant's
therapist made prior to her reporting the incident to police
that also cast dispersions on the accused. With regard to this
argument, what is advanced is not collusion, which has conspiratorial
overtones and which would bring into question the credibility
of the complainant, but rather what was really suggested was
an inadvertent tainting of the complaintant's evidence affecting
only its reliability. I find no merit in this argument.
So basically, we don't really trust you at all or so we don't
believe that because she talked to her her therapist and her
family members and they said you should charge this guy. We don't
believe that is something rising to like collusion or something
untoward. We Yeah, we don't think that at all. So, GG. Next argument.
The nature and context of these communications was simply indicative
of a supportive network of people that wanted to help the complainant
in whatever manner they could. Family and friends provided comfort
and the therapist provided suggestions that had a therapeutic
objective. The fact that the people with whom the complainant
had contact with encouraged her to report the incident to police
or made disparaging remarks about the accused without having
been present at the incident or knowing him had no effect on
the reliability of the complaintant's evidence as related to
the critical issues in this trial that revolved around the essential
elements of the offense, the evidence. I now turn to the evidence.
Hold on one second. Okay, before we go to the evidence, let's
just read the let's
scares me the most. But as unlikely as it is, the possibility
of having my life back has been the shred of hope I've been holding
on to for years. If I had to go to prison for something I didn't
do, it would literally ruin my life. And I think that's all that
needs to be said. Put yourself in my shoes. Think about what
is happening to me as if it was happening to you or a loved one.
Really think about that. I love
Dude, uh I would have advised my loved one not to make up such
a an absurd lie that makes me look like a in court.
>> probably probably >> of my country. I respect
the legal system. I think it's right more often than not. But
false convictions happen and when they do, it's absolutely devastating.
Since the false accusation and wrongful conviction, my life has
changed completely. My mental health was destroyed. My relationships
destroyed. My finances destroyed. This cost an ungodly amount
of money. We're talking hundreds of thousands of dollars. And
that's not even talking about lost revenue from my channels being
terminated. They literally cut off my income. That is >> Oh
[__] he got Is that okay to terminate his channels?
I When did he get terminated? He must have gotten terminated
a year ago, right? I think I saw one of the videos is from 2024.
There's like a Yeah, there's an archive video from 2024. If he
got terminated after he was convicted, I don't hate it. If it
was before he got convicted, I do not like it. Okay. So [__]
up. Honestly, I wouldn't be surprised if they try to take down
my Instagram, which is another reason I avoided posting about
this because if I talk about this, they're going to try and silence
me again. I don't want to make this about me, but like >> Well,
it's not even it's not a simple thing of like if he he uses his
platform and the way he does this, like it was a girl he met
in one of his videos that he, right? So, he uses his platform
to meet women. I I think as long as it's like an essential element
of him ending up in this situation where he can assault someone,
then I don't hate the idea of him getting uh if he's convicted
losing his YouTube channel. >> Like guys, this has been
so serious. Like aside from everything else in my own city, people
hung up photos of me. I've been banned from gyms, co-working
spaces, establishments, apps, buildings, restaurants. I've received
thousands of death threats. Hey, dude. That's crazy,
dude.
Toron Toronto coming together to to cut this guy off. That's
nuts. What did he do? Uh, he very likely assaulted somebody,
it seems like. Well, very likely he likely assaulted somebody.
He tells some really unbelievable lies. Les here. If you haven't
seen it, you got to go back and watch. It's Yeah, it's a it's
been a wild ride. >> People have made multiple hour documentaries
defaming me, and I guarantee they don't have the actual transcripts.
They never even considered the actual evidence. They're just
running with what was posted in newspapers. And this entire time,
I've had to remain silent about it. Just trust the system. The
system continuously lets me down. I've tried to remain patient,
calm, stoic. I work out every day. I read books. I have an amazing
girlfriend, family, and support network, which I'm very grateful
for. But aside from that, MARCUS AURELIUS NEVER TOLD ME not to.
What the I have essentially become a recluse. And at times, it's
felt like I've been hanging on by a thread. And this is totally
different than who I actually am. I used to be confident, happy,
optimistic, and I was proud of working my ass off for years in
construction to become an entrepreneur and have the opportunity
to create content online. I was able to entertain millions of
people with my comedy videos. And I helped millions of people
with my self-improving content as well. And I had dreams of becoming
an actor and filmmaker. And all of that was taken away from me
for something that I didn't do. And that's not fair. That's not
right. I want to create. I want to provide value to the world.
And I don't want sympathy. I don't want to be a >> dude.
You you literally ran
the like you literally ran just like a pickup artist course channel.
You You were not adding value to the world. Shut up.
Adding value. I wanted to add value to the world by showing men
that they could work out and be the best men they could be. No,
we got lots of students doing that already. And as bad as they
are, at least like 50% of them don't. Okay, you met the you met
the there was a minimum bar and you couldn't meet that. Okay,
just don't if you do this kind of content. Now, I will say it
seems like a lot of these guys can't meet that bar, but that
was the only bar. That was it. you victim. And that's the toughest
part on my ego. I should be working right now. I should be creating.
I should be chasing my dreams and pursuing my goals, my purpose.
I should be posting things that provide you value, not talking
about this absolute tragedy that I'm barely surviving right now.
I should not be stuck on the sidelines waiting around. I want
to live. And the only remote chance I have of ever having a normal
life back again is if my appeal is successful. Whether you liked
my content or not, whether you like me or not, whether you know
anything about me, what was done to me was wrong. It was unjust.
And this process has been incredibly painful for me and my family.
I imagine it has also been painful at times for the accuser as
well. And I'm not trying to minimize her feelings here, but what
was a consensual date turned into being concerned about a >> Man,
I I have a personal anecdote I can never share on something like
this happening.
And I knew somebody who was in a situation like this that was
like
sort of like a maybe a professional association you called them.
I can't say it cuz you could look it up and and I like I can't
be really specific about it at all, but the guy got accused in
a similar way and he made like these same arguments to me and
I remember being like it really sucks man cuz I I like you like
you're this person as far as I knew them professionally always
a good person or whatever but I could just hear I' I've followed
a couple of these things online and I could just hear in my head
it actually ended up being very very very very similar to this
where I think the fact that this person went and talked to
um like the victim went and talked to somebody immediately afterwards
and said this happened. I think that works against them. And
unfortunately when he was telling me the story, he left that
part out pretty harshly.
And so I was like willing to I I went and looked it up after.
And I'm like, "Dude, I [laughter] I felt bad because it was somebody
I knew." And I'm like, "Dude, that's that sucks cuz you left
out LIKE A REALLY IMPORTANT DETAIL that obviously was
Okay, that was obviously critical.
Uh I wish I could talk more about it because it is actually very
interesting but I can't. So yeah that guy faces will face some
consequences unfortunately
>> being circulated online. >> Sorry I had to be
super vague. >> And then that became something completely
different and at the end of that I was wrongfully convicted and
I'm not asking you to take what I've said at face value. I'm
asking that you review the evidence and transcripts in their
entirety and make your own judgment. No one is perfect and I
don't claim to be, but I'm an innocent person and I deserve to
have my life back. I want to end by saying thank you to those
that do share your stories. Whether you're a victim of assault
or a victim of a false accusation, I understand it's a lot to
go through, okay? And nothing in this video was meant to offend
you or minimize what you've gone through. I also want to say
thank you to those who still continue to support me because you're
basically the only reason I'm even here right now. And I'm sorry
to all my fans and everybody that it took me so long to make
a statement. I hope I can share more with you soon. Thank you
this guy definitely did it. This guy definitely did that. Okay,
this guy definitely did that.
We can now continue on. Okay, we've got we've got more of the
transcript to read. Okay, the evidence. Now, we'll be watching
to see like what exactly
like what exactly is in here cuz I feel like he wasn't he obviously
wasn't showing us everything, right?
So, I guess quick quick recap for people who just got here because
we are, you know, we've been watching this already for 2 hours,
3 hours now. Okay,
this guy is a Canadian former pickup artist. He used to do pickup
artists and like prank content on YouTube. Okay, he eventually
ran a course very similar to the ones like Myron or Sneo would
run playing with fire. It was this exact sort of like YouTube
channel plus a chorus trying to get everybody to sign up and
and pay him money. Okay,
he had a allegation from 2020.
The way he starts his video is, okay, the way he starts his video
is I was recording a consent video during this encounter. Okay.
And you don't quite get it from him there, but his argument is
he wanted a video saying we both consent to having this encounter.
But what he did was pull out his phone while she was blowing
him mid [__]
And then he got caught with his phone out. And his excuse is,
I was shooting a consent video.
Okay. I was shooting a consent video.
Bro, what? That was his that was his excuse. And he maintains
it in the in the video we just saw. And it's like, bro,
what are you doing? What the are you talking about, man? A consent
video. And then the judge, by the way, and then he's going through
the this whole thing, the findings, right? And the judge says
because he pulled his phone out during a obviously I don't take
this consent video thing seriously. and he goes, "This judge
doesn't EVEN BELIEVE IN CONSENT VIDEOS. This judge doesn't even
believe that consent videos could be a thing." It's like, "No,
the judge the judge literally doesn't believe you in this specific
instance because you're a lying. That's why
it's crazy, man." Anyway, I turn now to the evidence. This is
the judge's ruling on all this stuff. Okay, we're we're reading
the final judgment stuff.
I turn now to the evidence. Pursuant to section 655 of the criminal
code of Canada, the accused admitted and the crown accepted certain
facts by way of an agreed statement of facts, an ASF, which was
filed as exhibit 12 at trial. The most significant of the facts
admitted were jurisdiction, date of the allegations, and identity
of the accused. The ASF also set out a number of other facts
that had little impact on the determination of this case. Evidence
where there is little or no disagreements.
So although there were some minor discrepancies
in their respective recollections relating to leadup to this
contact, what emerged from the testimony of both complainant
and the accused was the following. At the time of the alleged
offense, both the accused and complainant were adults. Mr. Densmore
was a self-employed YouTube personality producer and the complainant
was a university student who was working during the summer.
By the way, he is I believe he's 27 at this time, right? 2020.
How old is he now? Hold on. Jack Densore.
Densore age. How old are you? How old are you right now? Born
in 96.
Jack Denmo. Okay. 96. So 30 now. Five. Six years ago. Oh no.
24. Oh, that's a that's no year as bad as I thought. I thought
it was way way way younger. 24. This is not as bad as I thought
then. Never mind. Somebody was telling me he was like 27 at this
time, but it's fine. Anyway. Okay.
Uh both parties did not know each other. However, in 2019, the
complainant and Mr. Densmore were both at the same university
homecoming. The complainant as a part as a student participant
and the accused as a part of his
uh job filming it for his YouTube channel. Although they did
not meet at the time, Mr. Densore selected a photo of the complainant
taken at the event and included it on the cover page of his homecoming
YouTube video. One year after the homecoming and during co the
co pandemic, the parties were matched to each other through a
dating app they were using. Mr. Mr. Densore recognized the picture
of the complainant and swiped right. The complainant recognized
Mr. Densore and also swiped right. Swiped right. This made the
match. Mr. Denmore initiated the contact with the complainant.
They both exchanged a number of Hold on one second. I just need
to message here. One, one second. One second.
Okay, good. Good. Uh, Mr. Denmore initiated contact with the
complainant.
They both exchanged a number of text messages and ultimately
arranged for a date. The first date fell through. A subsequent
date was arranged and the complainant agreed to meet Mr. Densore
at his home to go for a hike and then to have drinks. The complainant
arrived at Mr. Denmore's homes home at 8:35 p.m. He was given
a tour of his house which took approximately 15 minutes and then
the two of them left by car. They drove for approximately 10
to 15 minutes when they arrived to their intended don destination.
They both agreed it was too late and dark for a hike and agreed
to return to Mr. Densore's home. both or sorry, based upon the
time estimates agreed upon by both parties, the accused and complainant
would have returned to Mr. Densor's home between 9:10 and 9:15
p.m. Upon returning to his home, Mr. Densore offered the complainant
a drink, which she declined. Mr. Densore then asked if she if
the complainant wanted to go upstairs to his bedroom to watch
television. She agreed. Once in his room, both parties sat beside
each other on his bed and started to watch television. While
in Mr. Densore's bedroom. The parties engaged in activity that
was broken down into four distinct phases starting with kissing
followed by touching over the clo over and under the clothing
including the complaintant's exposed breasts and digital of her
third being oral and fourth being unprotected
course.
The complainant left Mr. Densor's home at approximately 8:46
p.m. Bro, what?
Oh, this is actually another huge deal, isn't it, dude? He says
he asked her to leave. Are we serious?
They went They did a tour of the house, then they went for a
drive, then they came back. They're there. Yeah. They could have
only been in the bedroom for 36 for no longer than 36 minutes.
Yeah. I'm sorry if you if you have like an hour and 30 minute
date and you're like, "Could you leave now?
That's not believable either. That's a totally unbelievable thing."
Right. So he said, "Well, uh after me it's I asked her to leave
in the morning." And it's like, dude, what? Wait, he might have
actually asked her to leave. But then, dude, you have to
now I have to understand what happened based upon. So, the judge
doesn't say that she was asked to leave based upon both of the
accused and the complaint that they could have been together
for no longer than 36 minutes. Conflicting evidence. We'll see
what he says. We'll see. In describing their evening together
and specifically with regard to the four phases of activities
that occurred, the accused and complainant did provide details
that differ, some minor, others more significant. I will only
address the significant differences in their evidence and the
implications of the same. The accused testified that the complainant
consented to all four phases of activity through groaning, moaning,
use of specific words, and her actions. The complainant disagreed.
The complaintant testified that while the first phase of kissing
was consensual, on two occasions during the second phase of activity,
she communicated through actions and words her disapproval and
lack of consent. The first occasion was when the complainant
was sitting on the accused. She testified that the accused bit
her exposed breast and she then pushed him away and leaned herself
off of him, signaling her lack of consent. The complainant testified
the biting of her breast was painful and resulted in redness
and swelling that persisted for several days after. In the agreed
statement of facts, the sexual assault nurse, who examined the
complainant's breast the day following the alleged assault, noted
no injuries. The accused denied both the biting of the breast
and pushing away. In this conflicting evidence, I find that the
communication of disapproval or lack of consent did not occur
in the manner or with the intensity that the complainant described
and ex accept the evidence of the accused on this point as supported
by medical evidence. So we agreed on this right that this part
probably she was a little a little
wrong on this and the judge agrees judge actually says by the
way both the judge everybody agrees with him that for this we
don't hold you accountable. We're not mad at you, right? This
clearly you you didn't do this quite to the degree she expected
or or said or whatever, right?
The second incident of communicating disapproval was during digital
when the complainant testified, she said, "Ow," to the accused.
The accused denied hearing this communicated disapproval or withdrawal
of consent as having occurred. In cross- examination, the complainant
agreed that during the second phase of the activity that included
the push and the utterance of ow that she was kissing the complainant
back and when asked, "Okay, that's a way you could still have
shown interest. You were still interested in what he was doing,
right? It could have been on this conflicting evidence. I also
find that communication of disapproval or lack of consent did
not occur in the manner the complainant described and accept
the evidence of the accused on this point. Notwithstanding my
findings that these two incidents did not occur as stated by
the complainant, I do accept the evidence that the complainant
that during the second phase and leading up to phase three of
her encounter, the complainant h was having some misgivings about
how far things had gone and wanting to end the evening and leave.
So I do accept the evidence she the complainant was having some
misgivings about how far things had gone and wanted to end the
evening
and leave. Now this is interesting because I don't know which
way this was going. Okay, hold on. at phase three being oral.
So, she was thinking about leaving at this point and the judge
is like, "Okay, sure. You were thinking about leaving." I don't
think that necessarily matters a lot if she is still like physically
showing signs that she wants to continue having sex, which blowing
this guy or letting him give you head. Either way, that's basically
already a tacit consent, right? Consent to the activity up until
that point that things could be No, no, no, Nick, that's not
yet. No, no, no, no, no, no. You're wrong. up until this point.
It could just be that like things are starting off a little rocky
and that he's like kind of up a little bit, but it's like, okay,
whatever. People make mistakes. People go too far, too rough
at some point. But whatever, you know, I want to make this work,
so it we're going to be a champ. We're going to keep our head
held high. We're going to we're going to soldier through this
part of this guy being terrible at Okay, we're going to we're
going to get through it. We're going to make it.
So, at phase three being oral, the accused maintained that this
was completely consensual
and that any issue that the complainant had regarding his videotaping
of that activity, which I will address in more detail shortly,
was resolved to the complaintant satisfaction. The complainant
took a different position on this. I turn now to the videotaping
incident.
The accused testified that during oral, he picked up his phone
and started filming the complainant. When the complainant saw
this, the accused told her that he was making a consent video.
The complainant denied that that this was said. On this specific
point, it is very odd that the accused would contemplate making
a video to confirm consent after the start and during oral without
first obtaining the consent of the complainant to do so.
Also,
no, not also, but obviously
it's it's unbelievable.
It is completely unbelievable and makes your testimony with regards
to this phase of activity totally unreliable, totally a total
joke. Well, this is per legal analysis, ligious gamer,
because basically the the strategy from this is trying to lay
out a framework for how I'm going to address things, right? It's
like whether or not she put her shirt on before or after
um going to give this guy head is kind of irrelevant to whether
or not she was assaulted, right? And the argument the defense
is making, the the accused was making was something along the
lines of well, she said she put her shirt on before when she
testified to the cops, but then during testimony here, she says
it was after um the like she got back up when she found out he
was filming and she put her shirt on after. and they want to
focus on that inconsistency and say she's an unreliable witness
and you can't take her seriously when it's like well honestly
that progression of events really doesn't matter that much and
any assertion from somebody that you would get that right after
months or years is kind of insane. It's kind of stupid to make.
It's stupid to make that assertion. Right? So what he's trying
to do is separate out things like these phases so that he could
say, well, the fact that she was not credible in this case with
regards to some small event that happened doesn't really matter
all that much. We're looking at the core
anyway, anyway, so at phase three being oral, we talked about
this. So the complainant denied that this was said, the consent
video thing on the specific point. It is very odd that the accused
would contemplate making a video to confirm consent after the
start and during oral without first obtaining consent of the
complainant to do so. His explanation and rationale for this
was simply too incredible to believe. I reject the evidence of
the accused that he was making a consent video or whatever that
really is or that he was told the complainant that he was trying
to film one or that he told the complainant that he was trying
to film one. This evidence seemed to have just been made up by
the accused in order to justify and explain away the introduction
of his cell phone at that point of his intimate encounter with
the complainant. Deletion of the video. The accused testified
that when the oral stopped and the complainant told him that
she did not agree to being filmed, he showed her his phone. He
then deleted the video in front of the complainant. He went he
then went further to show her another function on his phone.
How he was deleting the deleted video, thus making the initial
deletion a permanent deletion. By the way, the idea that he would
do this if it was just a consent video that wasn't a video at
all that didn't contain any is insane, right? Oh, no. I wasn't
recording this. I was just going to make a a little consent video.
The complainants testimony regarding the phone differed. She
testified that she was caught by surprise when she looked up
when she looked up during oral and saw the accused videotaping
her. She clearly communicated to the accused that she did not
agree to being taped. And in response to that, the accused simply
put the phone down. Contrary to what was the accused stated regarding
the deletion of the video, the complainant was emphatic in her
cross-examination and remained unshaken that she did not witness
any deletion of the videos.
She did not even see the phone screen. The complainant was not
even sure if she if the accused had taken a photo or video of
her. With regards to this uh with regards to this area of conflicting
evidence relating to the deletion of the video, the complainant
was credible and I reject the evidence of the accused as unworthy
of belief. Obviously
Obviously so. No. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Anyway,
this conclusion is also supported by the evidence elicited from
the complainant in cross-examination about her most significant
concern after leaving Mr. Denwar's home being the existence of
an intimate video of her and the potential impact this of this
on her or on her in the future. If she had witnessed the double
deletion that Mr. Densore testified to, she would not have had
those concerns. In short, having considered all the evidence
of the issue of the video, I reject the testimony of the accused
is unworthy of belief. The evidence of the complainant on this
point was logical and believable.
Yeah. Okay. So, it's not even like it's not even that
every element of this shows her being credible and him being
totally noncredible. Okay. In her testimony and chief, the complainant
stated that after the video incident, she got up and wanted to
leave. In cross- examination and based upon the time estimates
and complainant sorry the time estimates the complainant had
given on how long oral lasted being 5 to 10 minutes the time
frame when the video was made approximately 2 minutes. Defense
council suggested to the complainant that after the phone was
put down there were a few minutes left that and that she continued
to perform oral to which she responded it was possible. This
was raised a second time in cross-examination when she clarified
her evidence in stating that while it could have been possible
she did not remember doing that. Nothing turned on whether the
complainant engaged or did not engage in further oral sex after
the phone was put down. These answers given on cross-examination
did not diminish or adversely affect the credibility of the complainant.
It simply highlighted the time estimates she had given were not
particularly reliable. Okay. So what they argued was
right what they argued was
because she started because she went back to doing oral after
the fact that was proof that she wasn't outraged. She didn't
get up to leave. none of this happened, right? That that seems
like it could be important. She's saying it was possible, but
she didn't remember like she doesn't remember that happening.
She doesn't remember it going down that way. It sounds like autism,
but if if her testimony is that she was so upset when the phone
was put down that she got up to go leave and then he threw her
down. Now, I don't even know that that is the four phases yet.
We will have to continue through the entire thing and see how
this develops because I I thought that's what it was that she
basically went to leave at that point. She said, "I'm going to
use the bathroom." And then she was like, "I can't do it anymore."
And then eventually he like throws her he like grabs her and
puts her back down on the bed and forcibly her. Okay, we'll see
exactly how this time is laid out because we haven't even gotten
the the explanation of phase 4 yet.
In summary, in regard to the conflicting evidence, I conclude
that the complaint started to have subjective misgivings about
her sexual activity with the accused before the oral sex occurred.
These initial misgivings crystallized both in a form both in
the form of a subjective withdrawal of consent during the course
of oral sex and were then communicated in words to the accused
when he tried to film the complainant and she said that she was
not okay. At this moment it ought to have been clear that to
the accused that he had overstepped.
I agree.
Okay. Okay. The final significant conflicting evidence came regarding
the fourth phase of sexual activity. First relating to the preparation
for the unprotected sexual intercourse and then with the consent
to the execution of the same. The accused testified in chief,
so this is him, that after the oral sex ended, he told the complainant
to stand up, asked her to turn around, reached around her and
penetrated her digitally and removed her underwear. He testified
that the complainant did not assist him in the removal of her
underwear. He pulled them down to her knees where they fell to
the floor. Additionally, the accused testified that he, with
the assistance of the complainant,
pulled her entire dress off and it too fell to the floor. The
complaint's evidence was that when she got up from the floor
after the oral ended, she pulled up her dress straps and covered
her breasts and pulled down her dress and turned to the bed to
retrieve her shirt that she had removed earlier. No words were
exchanged between the complainant and the accused. The accused
continued to kiss her. She did not kiss him back. He turned her
around and bent her face down in the bed. He pulled her dress
up and pulled down her underwear. He entered her without asking
and without a condom and ultimately ejaculated on her back. She
testified that she had remained passive through this fourth phase
of activity. With regard to the conf the conflicting accounts
of how the complainant came to be positioned for intercourse
and the way her dress was removed, I rejected the testim the
accue sorry the testimony of the accused on these points. I accept
the testimony of the complainant as being logical and that she
had already had serious misgivings after the video incident.
She rose, started to dress herself, at which point the accused
continued to kiss her, touch her, and moved her to the bed. He
removed her underwear and pushed her dress up to expose her.
The complainant did not assist the accused to completely remove
her form-fitting dress, which would have left her completely
naked on the bed. Turning now to the conflicting evidence on
the issue of consent and to the execution of unprotected intercourse.
The complainant's evidence that she was that there was no consent
to this activity. Sorry, the complaintant's evidence that there
was no consent to this activity. What?
Okay, sorry, this is not typed correctly. She was passive and
although she knew it was happening to her, it felt like it was
not. She felt like she had left her body. Oh, she got the fawning
response. Unlucky. Unlucky genetic trait. Okay, fawning response.
Very bad in modern times. Okay, this is this is messed up. Mr.
Densmore testified that the complainant communicated her consent
and approval to this fourth phase activity by asking him to spank
her and by encouraging and directing him uh to intercourse by
saying, "Yeah, yeah, I'm not reading that. I'm not re What the
I'm not No, I'm not. I'm not doing it. I'm not doing it. I'm
not doing it.
I'm not doing it. I'm out. I'm not doing it, man. I'm not doing
it, man. Yeah. Yeah. Me hard. Me this.
Okay. All right. I'm not I'm not I'm not doing it. Should be
noted that the complainant was not cross-examined on these alleged
words of direction or encouragement that she said to have that
she was said to have uttered which supported the narrative of
the accused that they were words of consent upon which he relied.
I note that the accused testified to these illegit utterances
in a matter that was flipped and appeared to be made up on the
spot.
Oh,
dude, that's funny. That's That's actually super funny to me
because
the judge is literally saying that, "Hey, you were like I think
basically what the judge sees this as is
he was trying to imply that she was like into it and she said
stuff and then he like made up some lines she said on the spot
because he's an [__] He's a loser." Right? I think
that's what the judge is saying on the points the point of steps
taken by the accused in determining consent for intercourse.
The accused testified in cross-examination as follows. Question.
You also didn't take any steps to steps to get her consent when
you entered her from behind. What do you mean by taking steps?
I'm suggesting to you
uh took Oh, that you took no steps.
What does Sorry, I don't know what you mean by taking steps.
Like asking her, "Hey, can I put my into your right now?" At
this second, you tell me. Was there a step you took? I did not
ask her if I could put my into HER RIGHT, BRO. HE'S ACTUALLY
TETTOED. HE'S ACTUALLY TEETTOED. HE'S TRYING TO BE SARCASTIC
during his testimony.
He's trying to be like He's trying to charm people during his
testimony.
This is your life. What the are you
Did I ask her if I could put my like right this second? No. Did
I ask her if I could put my
No.
What are you doing? WHAT ARE YOU DOING? YEAH, REED. That's a
joke. He's making a joke. He's trying to make a joke during his
testimony. This is the joke he's making.
Is like, um, actually, do you mind if I put my in your right
now? He's mo he's mocking it.
But like, they're asking him seriously, did you take any steps
to ensure her consent? What your answer here should be, if you
didn't verbally ask, was I I paused to check and like just make
sure that she was like into it still, right? I encouraged her
to like participate. I blah blah blah. There's a bunch of things
you could do. It doesn't have to be you asking her, "Can I can
I do this,
right?" But he he basically says, "No, I did nothing."
Oh, sorry. Here, hold on, hold on. I was going based off her
body language, her moaning, and her saying that she liked it
when I touched her. The accused painting painted a confusing
picture in his evidence relating to pursuing intercourse. On
one hand, he was receiving specific verbal instructions, which
he appeared to equate to consent in the form of the words me,
etc., etc.
etc., which I rejected as unworthy belief. On the other hand,
he testified that he did not ask to have intercourse, but rather
took his cues from the complaint's body language, her momoning,
and the complaintant saying she liked it when he touched her.
What flowed from Mr. Densor's evidence was that he did not have
expressed verbal communicated consent to proceed to unprotected
intercourse. This court, having found no that the utterances,
me, etc., were not made, at best, what Mr. Densors had were reactions
of the complainant at the moment that when viewed objectively
as described by him could possibly have been seen as ambiguous
and in the circumstances and that he mistook them to be consent.
It must be made clear the mere absence of no or silence or acquiescence
or reliance on earlier consent to other activity could not give
rise to this defense. The question this then was did Mr. Densore
have recourse to the defense of mistaken belief?
Section 273.
I'm going to be honest.
If this guy like the the basic idea here is going to be after
the video is filmed, she's testifying that he was forceful at
this point, right?
That's that's what she's testifying. And
essentially when he's totally flip about the situation, it's
not helping him. I I it's essentially flowing from the judge
is saying after she was recorded without
It seems unlikely to me that she would be immediately back into
this right after it was paused and and you say it paused the
whole interaction. By the way, this is this is around 30 minutes
by the way. It's about 30 minutes this whole interaction.
It's sorry 30 minutes that they could have been in the bedroom.
They started watching TV first. So this is like a very very short
interaction, right? And he's trying to have us believe that they
paused and he made sure she was she was vigilant enough that
she made sure she deleted the entire phone from the sorry the
entire video from the phone
but also that immediately they got back into and she was like
yeah all those crazy things that he said
that is probably unbelievable
to the judge.
I tend to feel like that was unbelievable too. Like the story
about the phone is unbelievable. And so the idea that she would
be right back into it instantly also feels kind of unbelievable.
Especially when it's been like 20 minutes, 25 minutes tops that
they've been in the bedroom for watching TV and then getting
to like there basically just isn't enough time for this to have
really happened in this way in my opinion. I don't know if you
could convict somebody on this, but we're going to see how the
judge defends it. Okay, so the question was, did Mr. Densore
have recourse to the defense of mistaken belief? So, does he
actually
Oh, hold on.
So, is the judge saying that there's an affirmative defense?
Is there an affirmative defense of mistaken belief here? Is that
like basically saying he
What was What were the elements again? Hold on. We're getting
down to the end. Well, I'll just read it and then I'll look it
up after. Okay. I I want to keep reading. The provision sets
out that where there is where there is no evidence of the complaint's
voluntary agreement, affirmatively expressed by words, which
I have found did not occur, or by conduct which was at best ambi
which at best was ambiguous. It is not a defense that the accused
believed that the complainant had consented to the activity where
he was recklessly reckless or willfully blind to the facts or
took no reasonable steps in the circumstances to ascertain ascertain
consent. On the facts, I find that the accused was at worst reckless
when he proceeded with intercourse, being aware that there was
a danger that this risky conduct may have been unwelcome, but
took a chance or at best willfully blind, having a suspicion
that the intercourse was not welcome, knew that further inquiries
needed to be made, but chose not to make them. He took no reasonable
steps to ascertain if the complaintant would consent to intercourse.
Steps needed only to be objectively reasonable,
but assessed subjectively in light of the circumstances known
to the accused at the time. One asks, "What did the accused know
about the complainant at the time?" Nothing. They were strangers.
They had been together in this in his room for less than an hour.
This was a classic scenario where mistakes and miscommunications
were more likely to and did occur because they were strangers.
Additionally, the accused was preparing to undertake an invasive
and potentially risky activity of unprotected intercourse immediately
following his attempt to videotape oral. The context of this
interaction demanded at minimum that he pause, regroup, and obtain
affirmative communicated consent before proceeding further. He
did nothing. So, this whole thing where he says, "I did not get
any sort of verbal consent to restart the interaction." I
I will be honest, I'm slightly surprised this meets the beyond
a reasonable doubt
Not. I fully believe he did it. I'm just not sure. Like it's
beyond my reasonable doubt. I wonder if this went to a jury trial
how this would have gone cuz like I believe it totally. It's
beyond my reasonable doubt. I don't think anything else really
could have happened. Yeah. And then she got Well, I don't know
if he said she got redressed or something. It's It's just to
me seeming like unbelievable that these things happened. He caught
her filming. He says, "Well, we went through this whole thing
where I had to delete everything in my phone because I showed
her I showed her I was doing it and I showed her I deleted it
from my recycle bin, too." Because it was a consent video.
And she she literally even though he did that, she was messaging
people right after, right? Saying, "I think he has a video of
me. I'm really scared this guy has a video of me." Right?
so that didn't happen. So, it seems more likely that she got
up and was upset and somehow within like it's like a 10-minute
window, he'd been like, "Oh, no. It's fine. I'm gonna [__]
you. I'm gonna you. Let's just" and then he her and then she's
gone out the door in that 10 minutes.
That's crazy, man. Okay. Application of facts to the law. I,
by the way, I don't think this is like incorrect analysis. I'm
just I'm a little surprised that they went with this and charged
this guy because I just expect it to be like beyond a reasonable
doubt is a very very high burden.
Yeah. Anyway, returning to the four essential elements of assault
that the crown was required to prove beyond a reasonable doubt
that Jack Densore touched the person directly or indirectly.
This is all the touching was intentional and the touching was
in a nature of a nature. These three are not even up for dispute.
The entire the only thing that's up for dispute is D. The consent
that consent was not present at the time of the touching in question
took place.
Weird to write that it that way. The actus rees of this charge
required the crown to prove elements A, B, and C in the absence
of consent. The first two elements are objective while the third
element consent. The third element consent is subjective. So
hold on. In the absence of consent. I do think this is probably
true that there were some things done that were done in the absence
of consent.
Uh you could you could literally say that filming the requires
this, right? Like this is objective that she didn't want to be
filmed while giving a that objectively there was touching happening
there that was intentional and
right? The touching uh by Jack Densore took place in circumstances
of nature.
Are they laying this out correctly?
While the third element uh consent is
I find that the crown has discharged its evidentiary onus and
proved the objective elements. With regard to the third element
of consent, the consent element of the actress rees is only concerned
with the complainant's perspective and state of mind towards
the touching at the time it occurred. I find the crown also discharges
evidentiary onus and proved the lack of consent in two ways.
First through the credible evidence of the complaint complainant
about her internal and subjective misgivings just prior to and
during a ro in deciding that she was not comfortable and did
not want to go further. A decision which was manifest in words
and actions of further lack of consent at the time the accused
attempted to make a videotape recalling the mere absence of no
of no or silence. Subsequent passivity or acquiescence were not
consent. In these circumstances, all that was available to the
accused was of was the defense of mistaken belief, which as I
have outlined, could not succeed due to Mr. Densor's recklessness,
willful blindness, and failure to take any reasonable steps in
the circumstances to ascertain if the complainant consented to
unprotected intercourse. For the foregoing reasons, I find the
accused guilty is charged.
Okay, so it really does come down to the phone basically entirely.
It's it's almost entirely like you got caught recording this
woman without consent.
You immediately like after this
her and you say that she was moaning the whole time and but but
it's totally nonsensical with the idea that she got up. Even
in your testimony, it's nonsensical. Like your testimony is already
not credible for what happened during that time, but even during
your testimony, you got up and you had to show her like there's
no way she's immediately just like, "Okay,
No problem. Let's go. Let's go again. Right. Obviously, judge
is just salty. He's not getting some. Apparently, I I'm totally
on board with this. I do think it's a little surprising to me
that never let it be said that Canada's a culture cuz I I truly
believe that in this case
that like this is reasonable. This is the way it should be. But
I don't think most people realize this sometimes, right? I don't
think I don't think a lot of I do think some people are literally
reckless and willfully blind when it comes to stuff like this.
So, I'm surprised that that rises to the level of okay, he doesn't
get to make the defense that he didn't realize he thought she
was still consenting. I and I know
like I hope you guys understand what I'm saying. What I'm saying
is I think this is like
right, but I'm shocked the justice system is willing to look
at it that way. I don't see I don't see anything that he's saying
like fabricated evidence. I see nothing like this. I do see some
of the inconsistencies in the, you know, first and second phase
that he pointed out, but I'm not really worried about those either.
Very interesting. The argument is after you recorded her, after
you took the
needed to reestablish consent that it was okay. And you have
said no, you did not do that at all. And I find it totally noncredible
that after she was upset that you had recorded her, you did nothing
to reestablish consent. And she was just going, "Okay, now me
again."
Oh, you just tried to record a video of me blowing you without
my consent. Oh. Oh my god, that was so cute. Can you delete it
and then we'll Oh, let's go. Let's go. Yeah. Well, hold on. Pens
of code. The reason he's saying he had consent after that is
is that she was saying like, "Fuck me again."
Right. And then he finished in like a couple minutes and then
he was like, "Can you go?" That's his testimony
is that she was psyched after that. She wanted to continue with
the encounter. Yeah.
Yeah. That that's what I'm saying is beyond a reasonable doubt.
I'm surprised that you could say beyond a reasonable doubt here.
I think if this guy had just I I think he was he was credible
testimony away from just being let off the hook for this entirely.
Hold on. He admits she made him delete the video. The agree ass
was out the door within 30 minutes. But no, she doesn't. She
doesn't agree that he made her delete the video. In fact, what
the judge found was it's unlikely that that even occurred because
when she left, she immediately texted friends and said she was
assaulted and said something along the lines of like, "I think
he took a video as well." And so, the idea that he deleted everything
in front of her, well, that doesn't seem credible, right?
Why was she so concerned about the video being there if he had
deleted everything in front of her? I don't know. Less less credible,
it seems like.